İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar 5 Şubat 2025 Çarşamba günü saat 19.31 61. ders günümüz direk olay dersimize başlıyoruz kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Evet C++'ın modern C++'la gelen concurrency kütüphanesine başlamıştık kütüphanemizde çok sayıda bileşen var ve sayıları her C++ standartıyla artıyor ama sonuçta geçen dersimizde konuştuğumuz bir konu vardı çok önemli bence arkadaşlar sonuçta bu tür programlama dillerinin
concurrency ile ilgili kütüphaneleri tipik birer rapper sarmalayıcı çünkü asıl olan concurrency söz konusu olduğu zaman işletim sistemi
fakat bu modern C++'la birlikte C++ 11 ile birlikte dile yeni bir memory modelin eklenmesi ve concurrency ile ilgili bileşenlerin standart hale gelmesi
artık işletim sistemine doğrudan bağlı olmadan standart kütüphaneyi kullanarak multi thread ya da paralel artık amacınız neyse programlama yapmanıza olanak sağlıyor böylece kodları okumak daha kolay hale geliyor yazmak daha kolay hale geliyor
aynı kodu birden fazla işletim sistemi için kullanabiliyoruz ama tabii ki dedik bizim standart kütüphanemizin bileşenleri hiçbir zaman işletim sisteminin verdiği tüm olanakları vermeyecek
yine eklemeler olsa da işletim sisteminin kendi apilerini kullanmak durumunda kalacağımız senaryolar olacak ama bunun içinde ne yapmışlar dedik
birer ilgili sınıflar gerektiğinde tekrar işletim sisteminin fonksiyonlarını çağırabilmeniz için İngilizcesiyle birer native handle veriyor bugün bir örneğini göreceğiz
arkadaşlar şimdi threadleri kullanmak için farklı seviyeler var dedik yani örneğin ilerleyen saatlerde async isimli bir fonksiyon göreceğiz
o daha yüksek seviye ya da örneğin standart kütüphanedeki STL algoritmalarının bir kısmını yine geçen derste söylediğim gibi
birinci parametre algoritmanın diğer overloodunun birinci parametresine paralel çalıştırmak istediğimize yönelik bir argüman geçtiğimizde
algoritmayı paralel olarak çalıştıracağız biz hiçbir şeye karışmıyoruz arka planda threadleri kendisi oluşturuyor
ama en alt seviyede kullanabileceğimiz araç doğrudan stut thread sınıfı dedik ve thread sınıfını gerçekten de ayrıntılı bir şekilde
görmeye başladık ve şimdi görmeye devam ediyoruz arkadaşlar hem hatırlatma olsun diye hem de kaldığımız yeri yine işaretleyebilmek için
geçen dersimizde anlattığımız konulara ilişkin birkaç örnek kod daha görelim böylece hatırlatmış olalım
bir stut thread nesnesinin elimizde olması başka bu thread nesnesinin bir thread'i yani runtime'da akan bir thread'i temsil etmesi başka dedik
işte bir thread'in çalışmakta olup olmadığı yani bir thread nesnesinin çalışmakta olan bir thread'e bağlı olup olmadığı
ona bir adeta kesk esaniyet edilmediğini sorgulamak için sınıfın bull döndüren joinable fonksiyonu vardı
böylece eğer örneğin bir thread nesnesinin joinable olduğundan emin değilsek
onun join fonksiyonunu çağırmamız arkadaşlar exception troll etmesine neden olacak
yine destructor çağrıldığında thread nesnesi için joinable durumdaysa bu durumda da terminate fonksiyonu çağırılacak
işte bunu gösterebilmek için basit bir kod yazdım arkadaşlar
örnekte stut thread sınıfı türünden bir nesne ve bu nesneye task olarak ya da word load olarak
benim kullanmayı sevdiğim terim word load bu fonksiyonu verdim ve son dersimizden hatırlayalım
aslında istediğimiz gibi bir callable verebiliriz
geçen dersimizin ağırlıklı konusu buydu callable olarak neler verebiliriz
ve callable'ın parametrelerine argümanları thread sınıfının konstruktörüne göndereceğimiz argümanları nasıl geçebiliriz
şimdi 14. satırdaki kodda joinable fonksiyonu true döndürecek değil mi
ama 15. satırdaki kodda thread nesnelerinin movable non copyable but movable yani move only class olduğunu thread sınıfının hatırlayalım
dolayısıyla 15. satırdaki kodda tx threadini ty değişkenine taşıyoruz
bu da ne demek artık tx joinable değil ama ty joinable
yani 16. satırdaki tx joinable olup olmadığını sorguladığında efendim no yazdıracak ama bu sefer ty için yes yazdıracak
ama join ettikten sonra artık sadece tx değil ty de joinable değil arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar yani bir thread nesnesi elimizdeyken o thread nesnesi joinable durumda olabilir ya da olmayabilir
Mehmet Aleykici
hocam joinable true döndükten sonra join çağrısına kadar aradaki sürede joinable state'i değiştirebilir miyim?
tabii ki ama joinable state'i değiştirebilmeniz için şunlardan birini yapmanız gerekiyor
eğer soruyu doğru anladıysa eğer bir thread nesnesi joinable durumdaysa
bu state'in değişebilmesi için
a taşıma semantiği ile
başka bir thread'e taşıyabiliriz
başka bir thread ederken başka bir thread nesnesine bir bitireyim
evet
başka bir thread nesnesine
b
join ya da detach fonksiyonunu çağırabilirim
join ya da detach işlevlerinden birini çağırabilirim
geri döneceğim sizin sorunuzu
arkadaşlar
iki tane temel seçeneğimiz var
ya da destroy destructor zaten onu
hayatı bitmeden arkadaşlar joinable state'den çıkartacak
kendisi değişebilir mi?
hayır
böyle bir imkan yok
evet
peki
devam edelim o zaman
en son şu kodda kalmıştık
dedim ki join olduktan sonra yine joinable state'den çıkıyor
derleyip çalıştırayım Mehmet Ali Bey
evet
görüyorsunuz birinci yes yazdırdı
tx joinable
yes
ama sonra taşındığı için no
ty joinable oldu
ama join fonksiyonunu çağırdıktan sonra
yine joinable state'den çıktı
şimdi
thread sınıfının
diğer üye fonksiyonlarını inceleyeceğiz
arkadaşlar
ve aynı zamanda
burada
bir namespace var dedik
neydi bu namespace nesmi?
this thread
bakın this thread
bir sınır değil
this thread
bir namespace
o namespacedeki fonksiyonları göreceğiz
hocam thread taşınırken
iş parçacı tekrar baştan başlamıyor değil mi?
tabii ki başlamıyor
bu çok önemli
arkadaşlar
bir thread nesnesini başka bir thread nesnesini taşıdığınız zaman
sadece o thread'in mülkiyetini adeta oluyor
yani fonksiyonun tekrar çağrılması diye bir durum söz konusu değil
Mehmet Ali Ekici
hocam
foo fonksiyonunu çağırıyor ya
evet
foo return olunca ne oluyor?
foo return olunca
fonksiyonun çalışması bitiyor
yani
zaten thread nesnesini bu şekilde oluşturmamın nedeni
overload'u çalıştırmak
overload'u neden çalıştırıyoruz?
çalışsın işini yapsın diye
return edince de onun işi bitiyor
belki soruyu anlamamış olabilirim
ama soru şuysa
oraya henüz gelmedik
bu şekilde thread nesnesini kullanarak
çağırdığım
callable
çağıran koda bir değer iletecekse
geri dönüş değeri mekanizmasıyla
bunu herhangi bir şekilde sağlayabilir miyim?
bu şekilde değil
yani bakın orası için
başka araçlar var
geri dönüş değerini
bir şekilde kullanacaksak
başka araçlar var
fonksiyon bitince joinable state de değişiyor mu?
hayır
şimdi siz join fonksiyonunu çağırdığınız zaman
arkadaşlar eğer soru şuysa
ben şimdi anladım soruyu
diye hemen cevap vereyim
bunlar önemli sorular
belki temel sorular ama
arkadaşım aslında şunu sormak istiyor
yanılıyorsam göz atsın
diyor ki
burada diyelim ki
programın akışı devam ederken
yani 17. satırdaki join fonksiyonuna
yapılan çağrıya gelmeden
foo'nun kodu çalışsın bitsin
bu noktada joinable diye sorgulayıp da
true değer elde et
false değer elde etme imkanım
ya da böyle bir olasılık var mı?
hayır
çalışması bitse de bitmese de
joinable state'den çıkması için
join ya da
detach fonksiyonunu çağırmanız gerekiyor
Mehmet Ali şimdi anladım sorunuzu
evet
anlaşıldı değil mi?
yani öyle bir ihtimal yok
ona güvenebilirsiniz
yine
Alihan'ın sorusuna da cevap verelim
hocam thread taşınırken
iş parçacığı tekrardan
başlamıyor
kesinlikle tekrardan
zaten onu
tekrardan başlamasına
başlamasını sağlayacak bir araç da yok
Arkadaşlar şimdi dedik ki
diğer fonksiyonlara bir geçelim
fonksiyonlarımızdan biri
bu aslında sınıfın bir
statik üye fonksiyonu
hardware concurrency
arkadaşlar
statik üye fonksiyon
sistemde donanımsal olarak kaç
thread oluşturulabilir
onu söylüyor
söylüyor
yani
eee bu aslında fiilen
şöyle de düşünebilir
işte işlemcideki
core sayısı
ama yine
işlemcinin yapısına bağlı olarak
buna da çok güvenmemekte fayda var
yani şöyle basit bir örnek verelim
mesela benim siz de kendi
derleyicinizde
kendi makinanızda deneyin
arkadaşlar
see out
şöyle diyelim
hardware
supported
number
of
threads
yani bunu aslında şundan koymuşlar
diyelim ki
siz hiç
arkadaşlar task switching
yapmadan
yani
doğrudan
farklı
threadlerde
threadleri
efendim
farklı
corelerde çalıştırmak
istiyorsunuz
bunun
yapılabilmesi için
en azından
şunun sağlanması gerekiyor
tam bir garanti olmasa da
çünkü
derleyiciye ve işletim sistemine de bağlı
ama şunun sağlanması gerekiyor
ne kadar core sayısı varsa
yani ondan fazla varsa zaten
daha fazla core de
da arkadaşlar test switching olmadan
çalışma imkanı yok
hemen yazdıralım
şuraya alt satıra yazalım
thread'in
arkadaşlar
hardware
concurrency
fonksiyonu bakın
statik fonksiyonu olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
yani thread nesnesinden thread nesnesine değişmiyor
sınıfın genel fonksiyonu
evet
bunu doğru yaz diyor
ve
derleyip çalıştırıyorum
evet
bakın bende
on altıymış
evet
peki
şimdi geldik
şu
hem
getid fonksiyonuna
hem de arkadaşlar
this thread namespace indeki fonksiyonlara
şimdi
çalışmakta
arkadaşlar
işletim sisteminde
çalışmakta olan
thread'in
her thread'in
birer id'si var
ama
bizim kütüphanemizde
çalışmakta olan
thread'e ilişkin
bir id veriyor
bu id'yi
kullanarak
farklı amaçlarla
mesela thread'leri
birbirinden ayırmak için
efendim
debug amaçlı
loglama amaçlı
vs. bu id'yi
kullanabiliyoruz
ama
şimdi
bu id'yi
elde etmenin iki tane yolu var
burayı anlamak önemli
id'yi elde etmenin
yollarından
biri
doğrudan
arkadaşlar
thread sınıfının
non-static
ve fonksiyonu
get id'yi
çağırmak
yani örneğin
tx.get
id
get id fonksiyonu
bize
thread'in id'sini
döndürecek
ama burada dikkat
thread'in id'si
intür'den
longtür'den
bir değer değil
tamamen
derleyiciye
bağlı
ve
thread'in
nested
type'ı
arkadaşlar
thread id
türünden
burayı anladık mı
yani eğer
get id fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş değerini
bir değişkende
tutmak istersek
arkadaşlar
thread'in id'si
türünden
birazdan göreceğiz
bir değişken tanımlayacağız
zaten
şöyle yazdığımızda da
göreceğiz
oto x
eşittir
thread
tx
arkadaşlar
bu arada şunu da söyleyelim
biz şimdi konunun
görece olarak kolay
taraflarındayız
yani
senkronizasyon konularına
gelince
karmaşıklık artıyor
öğrenilmesi gereken
detay artıyor
bilmemiz gereken
fonksiyon sayısı
sınıf sayısı
artıyor
emiram
biraz önce söyledim
belki orada
derste değildiniz
şöyle
dedim ki
emiranın da
sorusuna cevap vereyim
eee
bu
multi thread
programlama için
concurrency kütüphanesi
farklı
seviyelerde
birden fazla
araç veriyor
işte dedim ki
en alt seviyedeki
araçtan başladık
biz
ama
daha yüksek seviyede
ismi
asing
olan bir fonksiyon
var
arka planda
tredi kendisi oluşturuyor
ve üstelik
bu
tredi doğrudan
kullanmaya göre
önemli bir avantajı da
çağrılan
kolabılın
geri dönüş değerini
asingle
işte arkadaki
future
ve promise
sınıfları
sınıflarını kullanıyor
ne yapabiliyoruz
elde edebiliyoruz
hatta dedim
ondan da
daha yüksek seviye
şu kabul edilmeli
STL algoritmaları
değerli arkadaşlar
hepsi değil
ama büyük bir çoğunluğu
multi thread
paralel
çalıştırılabiliyor
artık
hiçbir şey yapmıyorsunuz
mesela diyelim ki
sort fonksiyonunu
siz
paralel çalıştırmak
istiyorsunuz
daha hızlı çalışsın
diye
zaten bu testleri
yapacağız
o noktaya gelince
diyelim ki
bir vektörü sıralarken
single thread
çalıştığında
sıralama süresi
daha uzun olacak
ama paralel çalıştırdığımızda
daha kısa olacak
işte bu paralel çalıştırma
için muhtemelen
kullanıyorsunuz
bazı üçüncü parti
kütüphaneler de var
ama giderek zaten
ne oluyor
C++
nereye doğru evriliyor
üçüncü parti
kütüphane
kullanma ihtiyacı
minimize edilsin
yani her zaman olacak ama
peki
şimdi bakın
TX
get
id
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
get id fonksiyonunun
geri dönüşleri
thread'in
id
türünde
dolayısıyla
bu fonksiyonu
eğer
geri dönüş değerini
bir değişkendi
auto type deduction
olmadan
kullansaydım
o zaman
böyle bir kod
yazmam gerekecekti
şimdi
buraya dikkat
main thread'in de
doğal olarak
bir id'si var
chart track'lerin de
ve
standart kütüphane
thread id için
bir o stream
inserter'ı da veriyor
yani
burası biraz
yanlış anlaşılan
noktalardan biri
mesela ben bir
thread oluştursam
thread
TX
arkadaşlar
ona bir iş yükü
versem
bu da
geçerli bir kod
değil mi
diyor ki
emran
thread id günün sonunda
size t gibi bir şey
tutmuyor mu yani
o bizi ilgilendirmiyor
o bir ne olmak zorunda
değil arkadaşlar
bir tam sayı türünün
eş ismi olmak zorunda
değil
yani o
eş isim olsaydı
onu açıkça söylerdi
ama
şunu söylüyor
bakınız
cout
px'in
get id'si
şimdi
bu fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
çalışması
yani bu kodun çalışması
aslında
birinci parametresi
o stream
ref olan
ikinci parametresi
thread id
olan
bir
inserter'ın bulunması
nedeniyle
biraz sabırlı olun
hemen
geleceğim
evet
bakın
verdiği değer
tabi
join etmediğim için
arkadaşlar
bu arada bir şey
daha söyleyeceğim
bakınız
ben örneklerin
artık bundan sonraki
örneklerin
hepsinde değil
ama birçoğunda
thread sınıfını
kullanmak yerine
c thread sınıfını
kullanacağım
c thread sınıfı
hatırlayın
thread sınıfı
için c plus plus
yirmi ile gelen
bir rapper
c thread sınıfı
türünden
nesne
destroy olduğunda
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyor
joinable state deyse
join fonksiyonu çağırıyor
her da ettiğimizde
farklı id verebilir
değil mi tabi ki
tabi ki
arkadaşlar
evet
bakın
eğer şunu söylüyorsanız
başka bir örnek
daha verelim
şimdi ben
diyelim ki
join fonksiyonu çağırdım
fakat
yeni bir thread daha oluşturdum
taşıma senatinden faydalanarak
e şimdi
id fonksiyonunu tekrar çağırsam
soru bu sanıyorum
aynı id'yi vermek zorunda mı?
cevap hayır
öyle bir garanti yok
zaten gördünüz
arkadaşlar aynı id olmadı
e şimdi
ne işe yarayacak sorusunun cevaplarına şöyle bir bakalım
arkadaşlar
mesela
çok
klasik temalardan biri şu
buraya bakın
bazen
bir callable'ın
main thread'den mi
yoksa
child thread'lerden
birinden mi çalıştırıldığını
detect edip
ona göre
ayrı bir kod yazmamız
gerekebiliyor
bunun için
standart tek yol
getid fonksiyonunu kullanmak
ama getid fonksiyonuna gelmeden
önemli bir noktaya daha değinelim
bakınız
biz thread namespace'inde
orada da getid isimli bir fonksiyon var
oradaki getid fonksiyonu da
yine
thread id'yi döndürüyor
ama bunun farkı ne
eğer ben bu fonksiyonu
diyelim ki
bir fonksiyon içinde çağırırsam
bir callable içinde çağırırsam
callable'ın kodu içinde
o callable'ı hangi thread çalıştırıyorsa
onun id'sini döndürecek
burayı anlamamız önemli
mesela bakınız
çok dikkatliyseniz bu kod bence çok önemli
izin
thread
efendim
bu
bir fonksiyon
callable
bu fonksiyonu çağırıldığında
değerli arkadaşlar
thread id'sini yazdırsın
nasıl
thread
thread id
in
function
bu
is
this thread'in
this thread namespace'inin
getid fonksiyonu
ama
main fonksiyonunda da
tx'in id'sini yazdırayım
şuradan kopya çekelim
tx getid eşittir
tx getid
ve join edelim
tx join
değerli çalıştırıyorum
evet bakın görüyorsunuz değil mi
id'yi aynı
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ama şimdi
bir başka örnek
thread
tx1
tx2
thread
tx3
tx4
ve şimdi bu sefer full fonksiyonu içinde
arkadaşlar
thread id
is
so this thread'in
nesi
id'si
getid'si
bismillah
evet
this thread'in
getid'si
id'si
arkadaşlar
yalnız burada bu tür kodlarla dikkat edin
daha önce de söyledim
şimdi
cout'la paylaşılan bir nesne değil mi
paylaşan
yani İngilizcesinde shared resource
sizin
birden fazla thread
cout nesnesini kullandı
bu cout olmak zorunda değil
herhangi bir o stream nesnesi için de geçerli
eğer aynı nesneyi kullanıyorsa
birden fazla thread
işte inşallah bugün oraya kadar ilerleyeceğiz
bir senkronizasyon mekanizması oluşturmamız gerekiyor
o yüzden
şimdi burada örneğin
çıktı biraz farklı olabilir
hatta şunları c thread yapayım
tamam böylece join fonksiyonunu çağırmayacağım
yani
çıkışlar birbiriyle karışabilir
evet
yani karışmak zorunda değil tabi
bakın 14.408
15.657
17.802
27.240
aslında şöyle bir olanak da var
ilginç bir şey daha göstereceğim
bakın
iki thread'in
id'sini de karşılaştırabiliriz
eşit eşit ya da eşit değil operatörüyle
arkadaşlar
yani iki thread nesnesinin
id'sini de karşılaştırabiliriz
bu şöyle bir
olanak da sağlıyor
mesela
stut thread
tx
ben şimdi bunu
default initialize ettim değil mi?
evet
yani aslında buna bir task
bir workload
assign etmedim
ama şimdi bakın
tx'in get id'si
neye eşit olmak zorunda
bakın sıfır olmak zorunda değil
yanlış anlaşılma olmasın
ama default
construct edilmiş bir
thread id nesnesi değerine
eşit olmak zorunda
yani şöyle bir kod yazarsam
stut
thread'in id'si
default
construct edilmiş
o zaman if'in doğru kısmına girecek
see out
evet
doğru
görüyorsunuz değil mi?
ee
deniz akkuş
farklı zamanlarda çalışan
iki farklı thread'in
iki thread'in ailesi aynı olabilir mi?
arkadaşlar
aynı zamanda çalışıyorsa
id'ler kesinlikle
unik olmak zorunda
yani diyelim on tane thread koşuyor
ben onlar koşmaktayken
onun da id'sini alsam
hatta şöyle diyelim
bir set'e koysam
set'in size'ının 10 olması garanti altında
en kolay böyle açıklarım
ama soru şuysa
ben ayrı ayrı
ayrı ayrı
zamanda çalıştırıyorum
mesela bir taneyi arattım
ondan sonra onu join ettim
yeni bir thread oluşturdum
onu join ettim
aynı id'yi verebilir mi?
verebilir
evet
id'ler
data segmentte mi tutuluyor?
yok
thread id
thread nesnesinin bir
ingilizcesi ve
propertisi
rasul mamadov
hocam bu resource
monitöre ya da
test manager gibi programlarda
gözlediğimiz
process id ile aynı mı?
hayır
arkadaşlar bir kere
process'in id'si
başka
ve burada
şuna da dikkat edelim
bizim bu
thread id'si
yazımsal
bir değer
yani aynı
bir
proseste
cengizhan diyor ki
proseste thread
farklı şeyler
doğru
tabi ki
ama şunu da söylemekte fayda var
bakın
threadler için
isterseniz bir derste ondan da bahsederiz
kullanılan bir başka terim ne biliyor musunuz?
cengizhan
lightweight
proseste diyorlar
yani
hafif siklet
yani aslında
bazı durumlarda
proseste
thread'i
aynı amaçta da
kullanabiliriz
ama aralarında
farklı avantaj ve
dezavantajlar var
yani
bir proseste birden fazla
thread olabilir
ama
thread oluşturmanın
maliyeti
proses oluşturmanın
maliyetine göre
çok daha düşük
diyebiliriz
şimdi biz yine
konumuza geri dönelim
Arkadaşlar şimdi
yazacağım kodu
özellikle dikkat etmenizi istiyorum
bakın bir fonksiyon
olsa
voidfunk
ben bu fonksiyonun
bu fonksiyonun
main thread'den
çalıştırılıp
çalıştırılmadığını
ya da bir
chart thread'den
çalıştırılıp
çalıştırılmadığını
test edebilirim
nasıl test edebilirim?
Bir tane
global state oluştururum
bakın
thread
and
id
main
thread
id
şimdi
main
fonksiyonun çalıştığı
zaman
main
thread
id
eşittir
suit
this thread'in
get
id'si
böylece
şimdi global
değişkende
bu değeri tuttum
ve bakın
park fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
if
stud
thread'in
arkadaşlar
stud this thread'in
get id'si
eşit
arkadaşlar
karşılaştırma operatörü
vardı ya
main thread
id
o zaman
ne anlayacağım
anlayacağım
see out
call
from
main thread
a
child
as
call from
a
child
trip
yani
aslında
burada beni ilgilendiren
burada aile işlerin yapılıyor olması
şimdi örneğin funk'ı çalıştırıyorum
sonra
sonra da
stud
jthread
efendim
takes
pool
bank
ilerleyip çalıştırıyorum
bakın
birinci
çağrıda
call from main thread
ana thread'den
çağrıldığı anlaşıldı
ama ikinci de
child thread'den
çalıştırıldığı
anlaşıldı
hakip edebildik mi
evet
arkadaşlar şimdi
bir de şu
native handle
fonksiyonunu göstermek istiyorum
izleyin
bu arada
şöyle bir
özetle yapalım
biraz hafırlı olursanız
bakın şimdi
spook this thread'in
yani namespace'inde
kaç tane fonksiyon var
aslında sadece
4 tane fonksiyon var
nedir bunlar
biri
sleep for
diğeri
sleep until
biri
yield
öbürü de
get id
zaten bakarsanız
gösterecek
bakın
get id
sleep for
sleep until
ve yield
işte
get id
hangi thread'den
çalıştırılıyorsa
onun
id'sini döndürüyor
stud thread
id
nested type
sleep for
çalışmakta olan
thread'i
fonksiyonun parametresine
geçilen
duration
kadar
uyutuyor
yani uyutuyor
derken bloke ediyor
arkadaşlar
sleep for
sleep until
ikisinin farkı
bu
sadece burada değil
ilerleyen
derslerde
farklı birleşenlerde
de böyle isimlendirme
göreceksiniz
mesela başka bir örnek
wait for
wait until
hep bu
fonksiyon çiftinde
amaç ne
for olan
duration istiyor
until
olan
doğrudan
time point istiyor
yani
şu kadar
duration
uyusun diyorsanız
sleep for
örneğin
ama şu
time pointe
gelene kadar uyusun
diyorsanız
sleep until
ı çağırıyorsunuz
yield ise
diyor ki
ya ben
bu thread'in
öncelik vermek
istemiyorum
aslında
okuyucuya ve
işletim sistemine
bir nevi
veriyor
arkadaşlar
bunu
çalıştırmayabilirsin
önceliğe
başka bir
thread'e verebilirsin
yani ben
adeta
önceliğimden
feragat ediyorum
şimdi
sen beni
durdurabilirsin
başka bir
thread'e çalıştırabilirsin
gibi bir anlam taşıyor
Arkadaşlar
bir de
native handle var
işletim sisteminin
sistem fonksiyonlarına
geçebilmeniz için
bir handle veriyor
mesela
çok tipik bir örnek
thread kütüphanesinde
thread'in
önceliğini
değiştirmeye
yönelik
bir interfej yok
ama
işletim sisteminde
ister
işte
p thread kütüphanesini
kullanın
ister
windows'un apilerini
kullanın
orada
thread'in önceliğini
değiştirecek
fonksiyon
ya da fonksiyonlar var
ben de böyle
bir örnek vereceğim
bakın şimdi
diyelim ki
bir fonksiyon
volt
funk
bu fonksiyon çağırıldığı zaman
yine bir yazı yazdırsın
to see how
efendim
funk
is
running
with
modified
ya da changed
priority
şimdi
thread nesnesini oluşturuyorum
to thread
x
u
ama
funk
özür dilerim
ama şimdi
işletim sisteminin
olanaklarından
faydalanıp
diyelim ki
bunun priority'sini
değiştireceğim
ama
bu işletim sisteminin
fonksiyonu
o yüzden
ne yapıyorum
bakın
auto handle
eşittir
işte burada
bunun türü de
göreceksiniz
x'in
native handle
fonksiyonu
native handle'ın
arkadaşlar
stu thread'in
native handle type
tamamen
denliyiciye bağlı
bir türden
değer
döndürdüğünü
görüyorsunuz
evet
yani
bu mesela
windows ortamında
tipik olarak
aslında
void pointer
evet
şurası
tamam
şimdi
artık
işletim sistemini
mesela
windows
aya include
edelim
include
arkadaşlar
windows
nokta
neydi
fonksiyonun ismi
set thread priority
set
windows
surflerinde camel case kullanıyorlar
set
thread
priority
gelmedi ama
evet geldi şimdi
set thread priority
bakın şimdi
birinci parametresi handle
yani
o thread'in handle'ı
ikinci parametresi de aslında
aslında
bir
unix de
unix de aynı değil
arkadaşlar
ayrı bir
tür var
underscore t ile biten
set thread
şu örneği tamamen
birinci parametresi görüyorsunuz
handle
ikinci parametresi
aslında
eee
arkadaşlar
inter'den
makro ya da
enum
burada mesela
thread
bazı
makrolar var
thread
priority
gelecek şimdi
thread
priority
yanlış mı
yazıyorum
priority
evet
mesela
highest
görüyorsunuz değil mi
şu değerlerden birini geçen
emran
thread priority
down normal
below normal
error return
highest
idle
vesaire
ben
highest'ı vereyim
yani böylece
en yüksek
önceliği alacak
arkadaşlar
evet
ama
bu fonksiyon da
boolean değer döndürüyor
derken
hata kodu döndürebiliyor
if
sıfır döndürürse
arkadaşlar
başarılı
özür dilerim
boolean true
döndürürse
başarılı
see out
priority
set
successfully
efendim
as
bir yere
error
in
setting
priority
in
setting
priority
evet
ve
paves
join
anlayalım
yani
native handle kullanımına sadece bir örnek olsun diye yazdım
priority set
successfully
funk is running
with modified priority
belki
c++'ın
daha sonraki standartında
mesela bu bile ne olabilir
standart kütüphaneye eklenebilir
şimdi slip until fonksiyonu için bir örnek yazayım
sleep for için zaten örnek yaptık arkadaşlar
mesela sleep for için örnek
son derece basit
see out
merhaba
tut
this thread
sleep for
herhangi bir duration verebilirim
yani duration
template'in herhangi bir specialization'ını verebilirim
prono başlık dosyasını dahil ettim
using namespace
stoot literals
krono başlık dosyasını dahil ettim
using
namespace
stoot
literals
mesela
milisaniye
buraya mesela
mesela
milisaniye
buraya mesela kendi diyelim ki
geçen
krono kütüphanesini incelediğimiz dersi hatırlayın
bisek diye bir türüm var
o türden de bir argüman geçebilir miyim
evet işte bakın duration'ın avantajı da bu
şimdi
bu kadar uyudu
sit
see out
merhaba
dünya
evet
üçün
500 milisaniye demek
üç buçuk saniye demek
ama diyelim ki
burada
daha
güzel bir şey yapalım
bakın
duration'ın
hatırlayalım eski konuları
stoot
prono'nun
duration template'inin
double açılımı
arkadaşlar
böylece
ikinci
template parametresi
ratio
olacak
böylece
gerçek sayı
saniye olacak
ve
ne diyelim
1.467
saniye
oldu şimdi
yani burada
amaç
herhangi bir duration
türünden
template olduğu için
argüman
gönderebileceğimi göstermek
evet
ama
slip-out ile
daha farklı
şimdi slip-out ile
güzel bir kod yazmaya çalışalım
bizim bir tane fonksiyonumuz olsun
ask
diyelim
fonksiyonu da
bir tane
search değeri alalım
bir de
şimdilik
saniye değeri alalım
ki bu
milisaniye vesaire
de olabilirdi
ve
izleyin şimdi
auto
next time
yani bir sonraki zaman için
stoot
önce
çağrıldığı zamanı alıyorum
stoot
crono
efendim
system clock
now
şimdi count
kez dönen bir döngü oluşturayım
while
count
eksi eksi
meşhur idiomuz
döngünün her durumda
next time değişkeninin değerini
değiştireyim
next time
artı eşit
arkadaşlar
seconds türünü kullanıyorum
stoot
crono
seconds
sec
hatırlayın
time point'e
duration eklediğimde
yine time point elde ediyorum
ve şimdi
cout
time değerini yazdıralım
onu da nasıl yazdıralım
to time pay fonksiyonumuz vardı
stoot
system clock
crono
cout
system clock
Ne yapabileceğiz? Arkadaşlar
gözlemleyebileceğiz. Ama
neyi çağırıyorum şimdi?
Biz thread'in
sleep for no değil de
sleep until
ne? Bakın
sleep until diğerinden farklı olarak
bizden time point istiyor.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz? Evet
time point de next time.
Necati
kodu anlamadım diyorsanız
şimdi anlaşılacak merak etmeyin.
Ben örneğin
bu fonksiyonu
ask fonksiyonunu
herhangi bir thread'den de
çalıştırabilmiyorum. Thread'den çalışmamız
tut
C thread
arkadaşlar
ne diyelim? Tx
ask'i
çalıştır
10 kez
ya da 20 kez bu yaşı yap
ve her
bir saniyede bir.
C thread
olduğu için
join fonksiyonunu
çağırmıyorum.
Herleyip çalıştırıyorum.
Bakın bunlar
time tag
görüyorsunuz değil mi?
77, 78, 79
tabi bu
benim
sistemimde
Unix epoku
olduğu için
00'dan
geçen
saniye sayısı.
Şimdi değiştirelim
5 kez
3 saniye
6 saniye
8, 11
olacak
14 olacak
öyle gidecek
Evet
Peki
Arkadaşlar
Efendim nereye
geldik şimdi?
Thread
sleep until
fonksiyonunu
gördük.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
önemli bir alt başlığa
geçelim.
Tekrar buraya
geri dönmek
özelle
önemli bir alt
başlığa
geçelim.
Bu
thread kütüphanesinde
başka neler
var?
Şimdi
oraya geleceğiz.
Arkadaşlar
thread kütüphanesindeki
öğelerden
bir tanesi de
ya da
C++
modern C++
da eklenen
öğelerden
bir tanesi de
ne
tahmin edin
sadece
bir
threadde
yaşayacak
o threadin
kodunun
çalıştırılması
süresince
hayatta
kalacak
bir nesne
oluşturabiliyorsunuz.
Aslında bu
doğrudan dile
neyin
eklenmesi
demek?
Yeni bir
arkadaşlar
storage
class'ın
eklenmesi
demek.
Şimdi
normalde
buraya gelene
kadar bizim
storage
class'larımız
neydi?
Otomatik
statik
ve
bir de
neydi
arkadaşlar?
Dynamic
Emirhan
Çelik
burada
J-thread
değil
thread
kullansak
ne olurdu?
Hiçbir şey
olmazdı ama
join
fonksiyonunu
çağırmamız
gerekirdi.
Başka
hiçbir fark
yok.
J-thread'e
sonra tekrar
geri döneceğim ama
önce Emirhan
Bey'in sorusunun
cevabını
verelim
arkadaşlar.
Eğer
burada
J-thread'i
değil de
thread'i
kullansaydım
J-thread
ne yapıyor?
Bu
nesnenin
ömrü
bittiğinde
yani
örneğin
programın
akışı
buraya
geldiğinde
J-thread
nesnesinin
scope'u
bittiğinde
destructor
çağırılacak.
Destructor
da ne
yapacak?
Eğer
joinable
state'de
ise
join
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak.
Yani
join
fonksiyonunu
çağırmayı
artık
otomatik
hale
getiriyoruz.
Onu
sarmalayan
bir
ray
sınıfı.
Bu
da
neden
gerekiyor?
Bunu
söylemeye
gerek
var
mı?
Aslında
biraz
ondan
da
bahsedelim
madem
Emran
söyledi
arkadaşlar.
Mesela
siz
diyelim ki
bir
thread
yarattınız.
Stood
herhangi
bir
fonksiyon
içinde.
Buraya
dikkat.
Void
funk
Stood
thread
PX
Bu
da
E
Şimdi
siz
ne
yapacaksınız?
Burada
join
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız.
İşiniz bitince
değil mi?
Ya
burada bir
exception
throw
ederse
yani
join
fonksiyonuna
yapılan
çağrıdan
önce
programın
akışı
exception
ile
çıkarsa
yani
gönderilen
exception
nedeniyle
çıkarsa
join
fonksiyonu
çağrılmayacak
ve
terminate
çağrılacak.
Öyle
değil mi?
Ama
biz ne
istiyoruz?
Böyle
senaryolarda
da
yine
join
olsun.
Yani
terminate
çağrılmasın.
O
zaman
böyle
yazmak
yerine
burada
J-threat
sınıfını
kullanırsak
join
etmiyoruz
ve
iki tane
tipik
bakan
rayi
teması
daha önce
defalarca
gördük.
Şimdi
iki tane
ihtimal
var.
Biri
buradaki
kodlar
exception
throw
etmeyecek.
Programın
akışı
buraya
gelecek.
TX'in
destructor'ı
çağrılacak
scope'unun
sonuna
geldiği için
ve
destructor
threat
nesnesi
için
sarmaladığı
threat
nesnesi
için
join
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak.
Joinable
state'li
olduğu için
emir
an.
Ama
ikinci
ihtimal
burada
çalışan
kod
exception
throw
ettiğinde
o
exception
yakalanacak.
Stack
unwinding
olduğu
için
arkadaşlar
ne
olacak?
Stack
unwinding
sürecinde
yine
J-threat
nesnesinin
destructor'ı
çağrılacak.
O da
yine
threat'i
join edecek.
Yani artık
exception
handling'e karşı
a
bir güvence
elde etmiş
oluyorsunuz
ve
manuel olarak
manuel'i
burada ne
anlamda
kullandığımı
biliyorsunuz
join
fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
zorunda
kalmıyorsunuz.
Tabi tabi
alan diyor ki
smart pointer'lar
gibi.
Tabi
smart pointer'lara
burada
benzediği
nokta ne
değerli
arkadaşlar
aslında
rayı
sınıfı
olması.
Rayı
sınıfı
ne
demek?
Destructor'ı
çağrıldığında
destructor
kaynağı
geri
veriyor.
Böylece
nesnenin
ömrü
normal
yolla
biterse
destructor
çağrılıyor
kaynağı
veriyor.
Ama
exception
throw
edilirse
de
stack
unwinding
sürecinde
arkadaşlar
otomatik
ömürlü
nesneler
için
destructor
çağrıldığında
yine
destructor
kaynağı
geri
veriyor.
Evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi tekrar
kaldığımız yere
geri dönelim.
C'ye de
daha sonraki
standart
da eklendi
ama
C'de
derleyişler
tipik olarak
opsiyonel olduğu
için destek
vermiyorlar.
Şimdi
yeni bir
storage
kategorisi
var.
Ne
dedik?
Bir
otomatik
storage var.
Storage
class
deniyor
buna.
İki
static
storage
var.
Burası
biraz
bizi zorlayabilir.
Arkadaşlar
üç
dynamic
storage
var.
Ve
dört
red
local
storage
var.
Red
local
storage
şimdi
otomatik
static
dynamic
ne demek
bunları
açıklama gereği
duymuyorum
zaten
biliyorsunuz.
Ama
red
local
modern
C++
eklenen
bir
keyword
ve
bir değişkenin
tanımında
red
local
keyword
kullanırsanız
ona
specifier
diyelim
arkadaşlar
storage
class
specifier
red
local
specifier
kullanırsak
söz
konusu
değişken
o
thread'e
özgü
bir
değişken
yani
örneğin
kodu
20 tane
ayrı
thread
çalıştırsa
her
thread'in
ayrı
bir
thread
local
değişkeni
var.
Dolayısıyla
bu neyi
sağlıyor?
Thread'lerin
hem
thread'in
ulaşabileceği
bir değişken
ama
aynı kodu
birden fazla
thread
çalıştırdığında
onların
birden fazla
ayrı
değişkeni
olacak.
Bu çok
önemli.
Böylece
senkronizasyon
ihtiyacı
doğmayacak.
Mesela
aynı global
değişkeni
birden fazla
thread
ulaşsaydı
erişseydi
en az
biri
yazma
amaçla
eriştiğinde
ilerleyen
dakikalarda
göreceğimiz
ya da
saatlerde
göreceğimiz
senkronizasyon
mekanizmalarından
birini
kullanacaktık.
Ama
thread
local'da
sadece
o thread
dolu
kullanabildiği
için
senkronizasyon
yapma
zorunlu
ne diyelim
gerekleri
ortadan
kalkıyor.
Böylece
tabii
kod da
daha hızlı
çalışıyor.
Çünkü
onu
senkronize
etmenin
işte
mutex
nesnesi
kullanacaksınız
onun
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
kritik bölgeden
çıktığında
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
ama burada
hiçbir şekilde
bir senkronizasyon
gerekmiyor.
Yani
otomatik
ömürlü
değişkenler için
nasıl
senkronizasyon
gerekmiyorsa
burada da
gerekmeyecek.
Şimdi
biz
birden fazla
örnekle
şu
thread
local
storage
klası
bir görmeye
çalışalım.
çünkü çok önemli.
Üretimde
kullanabileceğimiz
çok yer var.
Yani
bu
ne değil
arkadaşlar
marjinal
çok nadir
işimizin
düşeği bir araç
değil.
Tam tersi
monthly thread
programlamada
en çok
kullanılan
araçlardan
biri.
Arkadaşlar
şimdi
statik ömürle
aradaki parka
bakalım.
Statik ömür
ne demek?
Eğer
statik
yerel
değişken
değilse
main
fonksiyonu
çağırılmadan
hayata
başlıyor
ve hayatı
main
fonksiyonunun
sonuna
kadar
devam ediyor.
Mesela
bir sınıf
nesnesi
olsa
global
bir sınıf
nesnesi
olsa
kursun
batkonlarını
hatırlayın
onun
konstruktörü
main
fonksiyonundan
önce
çağırılacak
ama
destruktörü
main
fonksiyonunun
kodu
koştuktan
sonra
çağırılacak.
Ama
thread
lokal
öyle değil.
Thread
lokal
değişkenler
o thread
çalışmaya
başladığında
ondan
bir nüse
oluşturuluyor.
Ama
thread'in
çalışması
sona erdiğinde
nesnenin de
hayatı
sona eriyor.
Arkadaşlar
bu arada
biraz zor
gerçekten
şu thread
lokal
konusu.
Çünkü
bazı ince
noktalar var.
Karıştırmamamız
gerekiyor.
Şimdi
thread
lokal
specifier'ının
kullanılması
scope'la
doğrudan
ilgili
değil.
Mesela
namespace
scope'da
thread
lokal
bir değişken
olabilir mi?
Olabilir.
Block
scope'da
thread
lokal
değişken
olabilir mi?
Yani
yerel
bir
thread
lokal
değişken
olabilir mi?
Olabilir.
Ama
onun
scope'u
doğrudan
ömrüyle
ilgili
değil.
Scope'u
ne olursa
olsun
thread'in
sonunda
hayatı
bitecek.
Yani
burada
global
olması ile
otomatik
ömürlü
olması
global
olması ile
özür dilerim
yerel olması
o nesnenin
hayatının
bitme
noktasını
değiştirmiyor.
Mesela
bakınız
thread
lokal
bu bir
keyword.
Yani
nasıl
statik bir
keyword ise
otopik
arkadaşlar
bu da
bir
keyword.
Değişkenin
tanımında
kullanıyoruz.
thread
lokal
mesela
int
ne
diyelim
civ
var
isim
bulamayınca
sıfır
değeriyle
initialize
edelim.
Yine
arkadaşlar
öbür
değişkenlerde
olduğu
gibi.
Yani
initialization
konusunda
herhangi bir
şekilde bir
özel
durumu
söz konusu
değil.
Mesela
bir fonksiyon
yazalım
workpunk
fonksiyonun
parametresi
birbirinden
seçebilmemiz
için
stut
string
hatta
const
string
bir isim
alsın
böylece
her farklı
thread için
başka bir
isim
kullanabilelim.
Yani
debug ederken
arkadaşlar
hangi
thread olduğunu
burada da
göreceğiz.
Ve
şimdi
bakın
hiçbir
senkronizasyon
mekanizması
kullanmadan
val
artı
eşit
ya da
val
artı
önce
şöyle
şimdi
daha burada
hemen
açıklamayı
yapalım.
Çünkü
kritik yer
burası
daha fazla
ilerlemeden.
Ben
func
fonksiyonunu
başka bir
kod olmasa
aynı
zamanda
thread'den
çalıştırsam
bu
kod
çalıştıktan
sonra
her
bir
thread'de
val
değişkeninin
bütün
threadler
loin
ettikten
sonra
val
değişkeninin
değeri
arkadaşlar
ne
olacak
mu
yoksa
her
bir
thread
için
val
değişkeninin
değeri
onlar
ayrı
değişkenleri
olduğu için
artacak.
Mesela
burada
ben
valin
değerini
yazdırsam
yalnız
yine
çıkışta
evet
vali
senkronize
etmemiz
gerekmiyor
ama
cout
nesnesini
senkronize
etmemiz
gerekiyor.
O yüzden
osing stream
sınıfını
kullanacağım
C++
ile gelen
başlık
dosyası
sync stream
evet
osing stream
tut
bir çibini
etsem oluşturabilirim
birden fazla yerde
kullanmayacaksam
konstruktörüne
argüman olarak
osing stream
nesnesini
veriyorum
to see out
doğrudan
artık
bunun
inserterini
kullanabiliyorum.
Evet
bu
senkronizasyonu
kendisi
yapıyor
ve
val eşittir
hatta
şöyle diyelim
val
in
red
red name
arkadaşlar
is
val
takip edebildik mi
evet
şimdi bakın
main fonksiyonu içinde
dört tane
ya da beş tane
thread oluşturalım
stud
j
thread
artık
j
thread
için ilave açıklama
yapmıyorum
ama
evet
stud
j
thread
arkadaşlar
t1
ya da t
şöyle denim
t
a
buna da
yazı olarak
a
vereyim
tb
d
olsun
tc
türk
c
olsun
td
d
olsun
hadi bir tane
da
te
arkadaşlar
e
olsun
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ve burada
main thread içinde
yine
main thread'te de
val
değerini yazdırayım
izleyin
val
in
main thread
is
val
şimdi bakın
evet
nerede bir hata
oldu
yani bir parantez
vesaire
eksik
evet
fonksiyonun ismini yazmamışım
bu kadar basit
e
native fonksiyonun ismi
punk
yani birinci parametreye
argüman göndermemişim
evet
izleyin şimdi
val
in main thread
is
zero
çünkü arttırmadım
onu
ama bakın
onların hepsinde
bir
çünkü bunlar ayrı değişken
olsa nesin
hocam fonksiyona parametre olarak
geçerken de
thread local
ömürlü olduğu
ifade edilebiliyor mu
hayır
fonksiyonun
az soruyu şöyle alalım
doğru anladıysam
fonksiyonun parametresi
thread local
olabilir mi
hayır
nereye thread local
yapabilirsiniz
a
arkadaşlar
namespace içindeki değişkenleri
bu örnekte olduğu gibi
b
yerel değişkenleri
bu örnekte olmadığı gibi
c
sınıfların
statik veri elemanlarını
efendim
thread local
keywordüyle
ona
storage
klasını
değiştirebilirsiniz
bu örneği anladınız mı
arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
benim bu sefer
doğrudan bir kodu
yazmadan
buraya yapıştıracağım
ama hep tema aynı
şimdi yine
dördüncü satırdaki
ibal değişkeninin
sıfır değeriyle
hayata geleceğini
görüyorsunuz
ama thread local
olduğu için
her thread'in
yine az önceki
örnekte olduğu gibi
ayrı bir
ibali var
Alihan birazdan cevap vereyim
bakın bir fonksiyona
bir nesne adresi
geçtim
ve
int'in nesne adresi
o adresteki nesnenin
değerini 42
yaptım ve
arkadaşlar
pointer'ın gösterdiği
nesnenin değerini
değiştirdim ve
ibalin değerini de
yazdırdım
şimdi
main'e bakın
ibalin değeri
burada yazdırıldığı
zaman
buradaki
ibal
main thread'in
ibali
dolayısıyla
sıfır yazacak
şimdi
ibal eşittir
bu yine
main thread'in
ibali
dolayısıyla
ibal eşittir
yazacak
değil mi
arkadaşlar
şimdi yeni bir
thread oluşturdum
işte yukarıdaki
thread funk
ibalin adresini
geçtim
ama
bu
ibalin adresi
aslında
main thread'deki
ibalin adresi
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ve arkadaşlar
buraya dikkat
p'nin gösterdiği
nesnenin
değeri
main'deki
ibalin değeri
dolayısıyla
9 olacak
değil mi
ama bakın
burada
ibali yazdırdığımda
aradaki farkı
çok güzel gösteriyor
buradaki
ibali yazdırdığımda
bu yıldız p
nesnesi
değil artık
buradaki
ibal
arkadaşlar
çalışan
thread'deki
ibal
dolayısıyla
onun değeri
yine
ilk değer olacak
alian bosker
thread local
specified'ını
kullanmadığımız zaman
storage olarak
thread local
storage'ına
default olarak
dahil olan
değişkenleri
oluyor mu
hayır
soruyu doğru
anladıysam
şu soruluyor
thread local
keyword'ünü
kullanmadan
bir değişkenin
implicit
thread local
olması gibi
bir ihtimal
var mı
cevap
hayır
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
bu örnek
bence çok
öğretici
şimdi sırasıyla
bakalım
ibal eşittir
sıfır
buradaki
ibal
main thread'in
thread local
değişkeni olan
ibal
burada
ibal eşittir
dokuz
main thread'de
bunu kullandığım
için
bu yine
main thread'deki
ibal
dokuz oldu
thread
fan fonksiyonuna
ibal'in
adresine
geçtim
tabi burada
geçtiğim adres
main'deki
ibal'in
adresi
dolayısıyla
burada
bu
thread fonksiyonu
callable
çalıştığında
main'deki
ibal'in
değerini
42 yaptı
ama bakın
buradaki
ibal
main thread'deki
ibal değil
artık bu
chart thread
de çalıştırıldı ya
dolayısıyla
o yine
sıfır değerinde
onun değeri
değişmedi
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
ve
join fonksiyonunu
çağırdıktan
sonra
tekrar
ibal'in
değerini
yazdırdığımda
bu yine
tabi ki
main'deki ibal
evet
arkadaşlar
olabilecek
en karmaşık
örneği
şimdi
size
göstereceğim
bunu
özellikle
storage class
specifilerinin
farkını
göstermek için
yazdım
şimdi bakın
bu da çok
öğretici
şimdilik o
mutex'i
görmeyin
mutex'e
inşallah
ikinci
derste
geleceğiz
o vasaniyesinin
sorusuna
cevap
verelim
main thread'in
ibal'ini
farklı thread'lere
pointer olarak
versek
undefined
behavior
yine
oluşur
değil mi
tam anlayamadım
farklı bir
thread'e
nesnenin
adresine
göndermek
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir undefined
behavior
oluşturmaz
ama sanırım
Oğuzhan Bey'in
söylediği
şu
farklı
thread'lerde
bu
birden fazla
thread
bravo
şimdi anladım
ben de ona cevap
verecektim
evet
kesinlikle
arkadaşlar bakın
çok dikkatli
izleyin
şimdi
shared
resource
ne demek
buraya
Oğuzhan Bey'in
sorusu
biraz daha
uzun açıklamayı
gerektiriyor
o yüzden
arkadaşlar
buraya daha sonra
geri döneyim
olur mu
bakın şimdi
aslında Oğuzhan Bey'in
sorusu şu
biz thread
çalıştırırken
hangi durumlarda
senkronizasyon
yapmamız
gerekiyor
hangi durumlarda
senkronizasyon
yapmamız
gerekmiyor
senkronizasyon
derken
burada
kast edilen
yani
birden fazla
thread'in
aynı
nesneyi
kullanması
fakat
birinin
en az
yazma amaçlı
olması
durumunda
İngilizce'de
data race
dediğimiz
durum oluşacak
ve bu
tanımsız
davranış olacak
eğer
buna karşı
bir önlem
alınmıyorsa
şimdi bunu
engellemek için
yine geçen
dersinde söylemiştim
birden fazla
mekanizma var
en
başta
öğreneceğimiz
tabi ki
mutex
mutual exclusion
ama şimdi ben
oraya odaklanmıyorum
ilk
soruya geri dönüyorum
peki
örneğin
mutex
kullanarak
mutual exclusion
yapma
zorunluluğu
var mı
yoksa
işte ona
senkronizasyon
diyorum
senkronizasyona
hiç gerek yok mu
şimdi tek tek
durumları bir sayalım
ki kimsenin aklına
şüphe kalmasın
soru
burada
yerel değişkenler
var
yerel değişkenlerin
türü
ne olursa olsun
sınıf türü
ya da primitif
tür
otomatik ömürlü
yerel değişkenler
için
bir senkronizasyon
ihtiyacı var mı
cevap
yok
neden
çünkü
her threadin
steki
kendisine
yani
farklı threadler
farklı
stek
segmente
sahip
birinci durum
son derece
basit
iki
statik
yerel değişken
senkronizasyona
ihtiyacı var mı
a var
b yok
cevap
yani
bunun üstünde
bir işlem
yapıyorsam
cevap
tabii ki
var
çünkü
aynı nesne
devam
burada
gittim
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesne
yarattım
mesela
t türünden
x
arkadaşlar
efendim
eşittir
şöyle diyelim
mesela main
fonksiyonu içinde
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesne
oluşturdum
o nesnenin
adresine
işte
Oğuzhan Bey'in
sorusu
buna benziyor
full fonksiyonuna
geçtim
şimdi
bunu yine
senkronize
etme ihtiyacım
var mı
cevap
tabii ki var
ister referans
semantiği olsun
ister
pointer
semantiği olsun
yani şu
başarı
seviyesinde
birbiriyle
karıştırılıyor
mesela bu
x değişkenini
main thread içinde
senkronize etmeme
gerek yok
ama
full fonksiyonunun
örneğin
a
parametresi
int refse
arkadaşlar
b
bar fonksiyonunun
parametresi
int
yıldız ise
ve ben
bu fonksiyonlar
içinde
burada
yıldız
p'yi
kullanıyorsam
ve burada
efendim
r'yi
kullanıyorsam
tabii
int
herhangi bir
tür olabilir
senkronizasyon
gerekiyor mu
yine
gerekiyor
tabii
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
devam
peki
thread local
için
senkronizasyon
gerekiyor mu
işte
hayır
çünkü
her
thread'ın
thread local
değişkeni
birbirinden
ayrı
değişkenler
dolayısıyla
birden fazla
thread'in
aynı thread local
değişkeni
birlikte
kullanma
paylaşımlı
ihtimali
var mı
cevap
hayır
peki
şimdi o zaman
tekrar
örneğimize
geri dönelim
değerli arkadaşlar
bakınız
buradaki
mutex'i
görmeyin
çünkü buradaki
mutex'in
tek
kullanılma
nedeni
burada
statik yerel
değişken var ya
az önce açıkladım
statik yerel
değişkeni
eğer burada
koruma
mekanizması
mutual
exclusion
olmasaydı
burada
tanımsız
davranış
olacaktı
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
yani
buradaki
lock
guard
ve mutex
nesneleri
tamamen
şu
artı artı
yeğenin
ne yapılması
için
arkadaşlar
senkronize
edilmesi
için
ama bu
aynı zamanda
lock
guard
nesnesinin
hayatı
buraya
kadar
gittiği
için
burada
lock
guard'ın
kendisi de
bir
ayı sınıfı
onu da
göreceğiz
yani
lock
guard nesnesi
destroy olduğunda
sarmaladığı
mutex nesnesinin
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
tekrar söylüyorum
buralar
şimdi biraz
anlaşılmaz
gelebilir
ama
bundan sonraki
en önemli
alt başlığımız
ilk alt başlığımız
ne olacak
mutual exclusion
konusu olacak
o yüzden
onları
görmeyin
şimdi bakın
int x eşittir
sıfır
artı artı
x
soru
bu fonksiyonu
fang fonksiyonunu
100 tane
thread'den
çalıştırsam
aynı zamanda
arkadaşlar
100 thread'inde
x'i farklı
değil mi
çünkü bu
otomatik ömürlü
bir değişken
kesinlikle
farklı
ama
artı artı
z
bu da
her thread için
farklı
ama
statik ömürlü
değişken
thread'ler tarafından
paylaşımlı
kullanılıyor
yani
y
değişkeni
arkadaşlar
aynı değişken
fang fonksiyonunu
10 thread
çalıştırıyorsa
onunla da
biz aynı
değişkeni
kullanıyoruz
buradaki
statik intiyayı
statik yerel
değişken
değil de
global
değişken
yapsaydım
yine bir şey
değişecek
miydi
hayır
yine
senkronizasyon
gerekecekti
yine
programın
akışı
her thread'de
buraya geldiğinde
o değişken
bir artacaktı
şimdi bunu
göstereceğim
koda bakın
hatta şöyle
yapalım
şu using namespace
kaldıralım
şuraya
stut
c thread
koyalım
arkadaşlar
ve join'leri de
kaldıralım
böylece
yavaş yavaş
gözümüz
c thread'e de
alışsın
bakın
değerliyorum
şu anda 3 ayrı
thread nesnesi var
tx'e 0
değerini gönderdim
ty'ye
1 değerini
gönderdim
tz'ye
2 değerini
gönderdim
takip edebiliyor muyuz
bu nedir
thread'in
id'si
yani
şurada
çıkacak
sayı
hangi thread
olduğunu göstermek
için
yani
bu ne demek
fun fonksiyonunu
3 ayrı
thread'den
çalıştırıyorum
evet
bakın şimdi
birinci de
thread id 0
otomatik storage olan
değeri 1 oldu
statik storage olan
thread local storage olan
değeri 1 oldu
ama bu sefer
id'si 1 olan
thread'den
tekrar çalıştırdığımda
funk'ı
arkadaşlar
otomatik storage
yine 1
ama bakın
statik storage
2 oldu
thread local storage
yine 1
üçüncü
thread çalıştığında
yine
diğerlerinin
artmadığını
görüyorsunuz
ama
arkadaşlar
statik storage olanın
değerinin
3 olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
neden
e çünkü
buradaki
thread local
her thread için
yani
tx değişkenine
ty değişkenine
tz değişkenine
assign edilmiş
bütün threadler için
her birinin
ayrı bir
arkadaşlar
thread local
ömürlü
yani
thread'in sonuna
kadar yaşayacak
bir değişkeni var
aradaki fark bu
burada bir şeyi
daha görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir şey
şimdi
ben
check gpt
sürekli
c++ için
deniyorum
ve gerçekten
ciddi bir aşama
kaydetmiş
korkutucu
bir aşama
kaydetmiş
çünkü
3-4 ay önce
abartmıyorum
hadi 6 ay önce
verdiğim soruların
biraz da zor sorular
soruyorum
%99'una
yanlış cevap
veriyordu
ama
şimdi
o %99
değil
tam tersi
%95'ine
doğru cevap
veriyor
%5'ine
yanlış cevap
veriyor
en son denemek için
şu soruyu sordum
tam bu kodu
ders için hazırlarken
şu soruyu sordum
dedim ki
thread local
değişken
arkadaşlar cevap vereceğim
merak etmeyin
thread local
değişken
yerel olabilir mi
local
thread local
değişken
olabilir mi
dedim
cevap
aynen şöyle yazdı
hayır
thread local
değişkenler
lokal olamaz
bir de kod yazdı
kodda da böyle
thread local
yerel değişken var
yanına da
syntax hatası
yazmış
tabi şöyle oluyor
hayır
verdiğin cevap
yanlış
thread local
değişken
pekala
lokalde olabilir
verdiğin kod örneği
de yanlış
dedim
bu sefer
tekrar
hani klasik
bu chat
çift tarzını
biliyorsunuz
özür dilerim
evet cevabım
yanlış
thread local
değişken
lokalde olabilir
vesaire
ikinci de doğru cevap
veriyor
bazen
üçüncü de
evet
dolayısıyla
mülakatlarda
falan
hile yapıp
bir taraftan
chat
cpt'ye
sormak
c++'da
iyi bir fikir
olmayabilir
basit sorunlara
doğru cevap
veriyor ama
biraz daha
soru zorlaşınca
yanlış cevap
verebiliyor
ama tabi
korkutucu bir şekilde
bunlar da
çok ilerliyor
arkadaşlar
6 ayda
ne kadar büyük
değişiklik
olmuş
chat cpt için
söylüyorum
evet şimdi
bir arkadaşımın
sorusu var
onu
şuraya anlamadım
diyor
bir onu
bulayım
evet
soruyu
kaybettim
ama
evet
Mehmet Ali
İkici'nin
sorusu
hocam
buradaki
z
function
scope'da
mı
buradaki
z
function
scope'da
değil
Mehmet Ali
önce
bu çok tipik
hatayı bir düzeltelim
geçen derslerden
birinde de
söylemiştim
bir kere
thread local'dan
bağımsız olarak
function scope
terimini
yanlış kullanıyorsunuz
en fazla
karşılaşılan
hata
şu ikisi
ayrı
scope'lar
bakın
şu üçü
ayrı
scope'lar
function
prototype scope
c'de de böyle
function scope
ve
block scope
şimdi programcılar
genelde bunları
yanlış öğrendiği
için
şöyle zannediyorlar
yani
sizinki de bu
hata ama
tabi eleştirmek için
söyleyemiyorum
gayet doğal
şöyle zannediyorlar
bu isim
fonksiyonun
içinde
oluşturulduğu
için
function scope'da
hayır
bu isim
block scope'da
function scope
işte
Resul ve
gayet güzel yazmış
sadece
go to
label'ları için
o zaman
birinci
hatayı
düzeltelim
function scope'da
buradaki isimlerin
hiçbirinin
function scope'da
olma ihtimali yok
çünkü
hiçbiri
label değil
ancak
label olsaydı
function scope'da
olurdu
mesela şuraya
bir label
koysaydım
out label'ı
şimdi
out isminin
scope'u ne
diye sorulsaydı
Mehmet Ali Bey
o zaman cevabı
function scope
olacaktı
o zaman soruyu
block scope olarak
düzeltip
soralım
z ismi
block scope'da mı
evet
arkadaşlar
ömür kategorisiyle
scope'un
scope kategorisinin
doğrudan
bir ilişkisi yok
bakın bir örnek vereyim
en klasik örnek
c kursunun
başında verdiğim örnek
int
i
c
ya da c plus
baz kodu
board
bu
int
x
static
int
y
şimdi isim olarak
scope'lara bakalım
arkadaşlar
c'de file scope
c plus plus
da namespace scope
bu ismi
c'de file scope
c plus plus
da namespace scope
x ismi
c'de de c plus plus
da da block scope
y ismi
c'de de c plus plus
da da block scope
ama ömür
iyi değişkenin ömrü
ömür
runtime'a yönelik
bir kavram
lifespan
bu
statik ömürlü
çünkü global değişkenler
olmak zorunda
burada bir
parametre değişkeni
olsaydı
parametre değişkenleri
otomatik ömürlü
olmak zorunda
parametre değişkeni
demin bir arkadaşım da
sormuştu
şimdi
mesela şöyle bir şey
olabilir mi
pre-local bir
parametre değişkeni
olamaz
yani bu
doğrudan bir karşılığı yok
anlaşıldı değil mi
parametre değişkenleri
otomatik ömürlü
statik anahtar sözcüğü
olmadan
tanımlanan
yerel değişkenler
otomatik ömürlü
statik anahtar sözcüğüyle
tanımlanan
yerel değişkenler
statik ömürlü
bu arada
konudan konuya geçmek
istemiyorum ama
statik yerel değişkenlerin
iki tane özelliği
bizi çok ilgilendiriyor
C++'da
birinci özelliğini
biz kursun başında
öğren
hangi özelliği
statik yerel değişkenler
fonksiyon ilk kez
çağrıldığında
hayata gelir
yani örneğin
böyle bir değişkenim olsa
statik int x
eşittir 5
ya da bu
bir sınıf türünden
de olabilir
statik
t türünden
t x
bu fonksiyon
hiç çağrılmasa
bu nesne
oluşmayacak
konstruktör
çağrılmayacak
ama bu fonksiyon
diyelim ki
farklı time pointlerde
10 kere çağrıldı
birincisinde
hayata gelecek
ikincide yeni bir nesne
hayata gelmeyecek
programın sonuna kadar
yaşayacak
ama
statik yerel değişkenlerin
bizi ilgilendiren
bir başka önemli
özelliği
statik yerel değişkenlerin
initializationı
trade safe
bu da çok önemli
yani bu ne demek
siz böyle bir
statik yerel değişken
koyarsanız
arkadaşlar
mesela
şöyle bir ihtimal
var mı
fankı
10 tane
threadten
çalıştırıyorsunuz
ve 10 tane
threadten
birden fazlası
ayrı
2 tane
nesne
oluşturuyor
cevap
hayır
işte bu
c++'ın ilk zamanlarında
bu garanti yoktu
sonradan bu garanti
eklendi
arkadaşlar
yani thread safe olması
statik yerel değişkenlerin
initialization'ının
yanlış anlaşılmasın
kullanımının
tabii ki değil
ama initialization'ının
hiçbir
ne diyelim
senkronizasyon
olmadan
yapılabilmesi
hani
klasik tabiriyle
thread safe olması
arkadaşlar
önemli bir özellik
ki
ilerleyen derslerde
bunu
bir şekilde
kullanacağız
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bakın
güzel bir başka örnek
daha
thread local
biraz thread local
üstünde
fazla duracağım
ama tabii
kod oluşturmakta
baya bir zaman
aldığı için
kendi dersten önce
yazdığım
kodları gösteriyorum
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
burada yine
thread local
ama
string türünden
bir değişkenim var
necati yazısıyla
ilk değer veriyorum
bu ne demek
eğer thread local
olmasaydı
arkadaşlar
programda
bir tane
name değişkeni
olacaktı
bütün threadler
bunu kullanacaktı
ve az önce
söylediğim gibi
senkronizasyon
gerekecekti
ama şimdi
n tane thread
aynı zamanda
koysa
her birinin
name'i
ayrı
ama her birinin
name'i yine
necati yazısıyla
başlıyor
fun fonksiyonunun
parametrisi
yine
string
name'e
buna ekliyor
mesela bu fonksiyona
ergin yazısı
gelse
name
necati
olmaktan çıkacak
necati ergin
olacak
ve ben
13. satırda
osing stream
sınıfını
kullanarak
yani
korunmuş bir şekilde
arkadaşlar
name'in
adresini
ve kendisini
yazdırıyorum
neden adresini
yazdırdığımı
tahmin edebiliyor
musunuz
çünkü farklı
threadlerden
çalıştırdığımda
farklı nesnelerse
adresleri de
farklı olacak
değil mi
resul
evet
şimdi main
fonksiyonuna
bakın
bir tane pointer
dizisi oluşturdum
pointer
dizisinin
6 tane
elemanı var
tabi tahmin
edebiliyorsunuz
her bir
threadte
bu fonksiyona
pointer
dizisinin
elemanlarından
birinin
gösterdiği
yazıyı
göndereceğim
vektörün
c thread
açılımı
tvek
ve
arkadaşlar
pointer
dizisini
range
base
for loop
ile dolaşıyorum
ve
vektörün
em place
back
fonksiyonuna
buraları
açıklama
gereği
duymuyorum
fonksiyonuna
adresini
arkadaşlar
ve
bu dizinin
elemanını
gönderiyorum
bu da ne
demek
bu dizide
6 tane
eleman olduğu
için
6 tane
thread
oluşacak
ama her
threadin
thread
local
değişkeni
farklı
dolayısıyla
arkadaşlar
burada
name
değişkeninin
hem adresinin
farklı olduğunu
göreceğiz
hem de
her thread
çalıştığında
biri
kendi
name
değişkenini
Necati Ergin
yapacak
öbürü
Necati
Özkan
yapacak
öbürü
Necati
Ersoy
yapacak
anlaşıldı
değil mi
hemen
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
anlamadığınız bir yer varsa
tekrar etmemi isteyin
lütfen
ve gerçekten
bakın
Necati
toptan
başka adres
Necati
Ersoy
başka bir adres
Necati
Özkan
başka bir adres
şimdi kodda
bir değişiklik
yapalım
thread
local'ı
silelim
arkadaşlar
fakat
burada
henüz
öğrenmesek de
ben
senkronizasyon
yapayım
Mutual
Exclusion
kullanayım
Mutex
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
ediyorum
ve
şurada
artık
Othing Stream
burada zaten
senkronizasyon
olduğu için
sadece
şurayı
kritik bölge
olarak
alsam
olur
onun için
de
şöyle basit
bir kod
yazayım
buraları
birazdan
öğrenmek
demeyelim de
bir dahaki haftaki
derste
öğrenmeye
başlayacağız
şurada
bir log
card
nesnesi
oluşturayım
stud
log
card
my
arkadaşlar
ve
argüman
olarak da
bir
mutex
verelim
stud
mutex
mtx
aslında
bu
log
card
bir
template
ama
bu
şekilde
yazmama
rağmen
sentaks
hatası
olmamasının
nedeni
arkadaşlar
tahmin edin
yine
sitat
anlaşıldı
değil mi
yani
template
argümanı
aslında
mutex'in
türü
normalde
şöyle
yazmam
lazım
log
card'ın
mutex
açılımı
stud
mutex
açılımı
yazmam
lazım
ama
class
template
argument
deduction
'dan
faydalanarak
bu
şekilde
yazdım
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
şimdi
aradaki
farka
bakın
arkadaşlar
bakın bakın
şimdi
çok güzel
değil mi
Necati Ergin
B7
D8
bütün adresler
aynı
çünkü
hepsi
aynı
değişkeni
kullanıyor
işte bu
shared resource
ve şimdi
bakın
Necati Ergin
Erdoğan
Demirkapı
Necati Ergin
Erdoğan
Demirkapı
Özkan
Necati Ergin
Erdoğan
Demirkapı
Özkan
Ersoy
Necati Ergin
Erdoğan
Demirkapı
Özkan
Ersoy
Toptan
Aynı
Nesneyi
kullanıyor
Çünkü
Ve burada
önemli bir noktada
senkronizasyon yapmasaydım
değerli arkadaşlar
yani bu kodu böyle yazsaydım
Mutual Explosion'la korumasaydım
tanımsız davranış olacaktı
şimdi bu kod
tanımsız davranış
çünkü
data race var
anlaşıldı mı
Alihan Bozkır
hocam peki
Thread Local
asıl önemini nerede kazanıyor
oraya geleceğiz
daha gelmedim
konunun başındayız
ben name değişkenini
otomatik ömürlü olarak
fark fonksiyonunda
initialize etsem
aynı işi yaptırabilirdi
arkadaşlar
ikisi farklı
yani bazı senaryolarda
otomatik ömürlü
nesneyle
aynı
amaçla
kullanılabilir
olduğunu düşünüyorsunuz
ama ilerleyen dakikalarda
görüyorum
aynı şey değil
arkadaşlar
mesela neden
aynı şey değil
bir thread'in içinde
birden fazla
fonksiyon olsa
yani
derim ki
siz bir thread'den
bir Colable'ı çağırıyorsunuz
Alihan dikkatli
izleyin
o Colable'da
bir başka
fonksiyonu çağırıyor
o fonksiyon da
başka bir fonksiyonu çağırıyor
buraya kadar
takip edebildiniz mi
yani şöyle bir
Colchain var
Alihan
F1
F2'yi çağırıyor
F2
F3'ü çağırıyor
F3
F4'ü çağırıyor
buraya kadar
takip edildik mi
ben şimdi
F1'i
birden fazla
thread'de
çalıştırsam
birden fazla
thread
F1'in
eğer
yerel değişkeni
olsaydı
hepsi ayrı
yerel değişkeni
kullanacaktı
değil mi
ama şimdi
thread local
değişkeni
kullanacaksa
burada
her thread
aynı thread local
değişkeni
kullanacak ama
bunlar da
aynı thread'den
çalıştırıldığı için
bunlar da aynı thread local
değişkeni
kullanacak bunu
otomatik ömürlü
bir nesneyle
yapabilir misiniz
yapamazsınız
anlaşıldı mı
evet ama
ilerleyen dakikalardaki
örneklerde
daha net
anlayacaksınız
kesinlikle aynı
şeyi değil
nerelerde
kullanılıyor
güzel örneklerde
vereceğim ama
şimdi bir ara verelim
saat 21.01
21.20'de
devam edelim
şimdi bir soru var
ben soruyu
yanlış anladım
diyor ki
Mehmet Ali
arkadaşım
sorumun devamı
olarak
sadece
ilgili
thread'e ait
thread local
nesneler
oluşturabilir miyiz
zaten
thread local
nesneler
o thread'e
ilişkin
yani
thread local
nesnelerin
zaten
varlık
nedeni bu
yani
oluşturabilir miyiz
değil
oluşturduğumuz
bütün thread local
nesneler
o thread'e
özgü
zaten
baştan beri
vurguladığımız
o
yani
bir thread local
değişkeni
birden fazla
thread'in
paylaşımlı olarak
kullanımı
doğrudan
mümkün mü
cevap
hayır
Mehmet Ali
ekici
hocam
verdiğiniz örneğin
ilk halinde
namespace'deki
tüm thread local
değişkenlerin
bir kopyası
oluşturuluyor
değil mi
her bir thread için
kesinlikle
ama ne zaman
oluşturuluyor
o thread çalıştığında
ne zaman
hayatı bitiyor
o thread
sona erdiğinde
arkadaşlar
şimdi tam da
Mehmet Ali Bey'in
sorusunun
cevabı
olabilecek bir
kod yazdım
ben arada
dikkatli izleyin
bakınız
MyGlass isimli bir sınıf var
ve sınıfın
Constructor'ı ve Destructor'ı içinde
Constructor'ın ve Destructor'ın
çağrıldığını gösteren
birer yazı yazdırıyorum
burada
Cout nesnesini
doğrudan
kullanmak yerine
O-Sync Stream
sınıfını
kullanmamın
nedeni
yine daha önce
açıkladığım gibi
Cout nesnesinin
de
kaynaşılan
bir kaynak
olması
buradaki
O-Sync Stream
doğrudan
kendisi
içsel olarak
korumayı
sağlıyor
burada
16. satırda
tanımını
gördüğünüz
Foo fonksiyonu
içinde
thread local
bir değişken var
MyGlass türünden
şimdi aynı soruyu
Mehmet Ali ile
birlikte soralım
her thread için
ayrı bir
MyGlass nesnesi
oluşturulacak
değil mi?
cevap
kesinlikle
her thread için
oluşturulan
MyGlass nesnesinin
hayatı
o thread'in
çalışmasının
bitmesiyle
sona erecek
değil mi?
cevap
yine kesinlikle
ama bir şeye
dikkat edin
bu aynı zamanda
Ali Hanım'ın
sorusuna da
bir önceki
dersteki
sorusuna da
bir cevap
niteliğinde
Fung fonksiyonunda
Fung'ın
çağrıldığını
yazdırıyorum
ve Fung fonksiyonunun
Foo'yu
çağırmasını
sağlıyorum
arkadaşlar
bakın
normalde
bu
otomatik ömürlü
değişken
Foo
özür dilerim
bu
blogscoptaki
değişken
Foo'nun
thread local
değişkeni
ama
Fung Foo'yu
çağırdığında
yine
thread'in
çalıştırdığı
doğrudan
ilk çalıştırdığı
callable
Fung olduğu için
Fung'ın
çalıştırdığı
Foo'da
o thread'de
çalışıyor
yani şimdi
ben
lütfen
28. satırda
başlayan
main fonksiyonuna
bakın
4 tane
thread oluşturdum
4 thread'de de
Fung fonksiyonunu
word load olarak
verdim
burada
2.
3.
4.
İşte bizim
hangi thread
olduğunu
runtime'da
anlayabilmemiz
için
ve
burada
oluşturduğum
nested
bloğun
nedenini de
tahmin ediyorsunuz
değil mi
çünkü
burada
C thread
nesneleri
destroy olduğunda
bu
noktada
aslında
T1
T2
T3
T4
thread'leri
için
sarmalanan
thread'ler için
join fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
ama şimdi
bakın
programı
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
ekran çıktısı
burada çok
önemli
birinci ekran çıktısına
bakalım
Fung'ı
ilk 4
ID'si için
çağırmış
sonra 1
sonra 2
sonra 3
bunun
non-deterministik
olduğunu
söylemiştik
yani
benim burada
ilk
yine uyarım
burada
thread'leri
bu sırayla
oluşturmam
demek
önce
Fung fonksiyonu
Fung fonksiyonun
argümanıyla
sonra 2
sonra 3
argümanıyla
sonra 4
yani
zamansal olarak
bu sırayla
çalışacağı
anlamına mı
geliyor
hayır
arkada
bu thread'ler
oluşturacak
işletim
sisteminin
kodları
koşacak
ve
hangisinin
daha önce
çalıştığı
kesinlikle
deterministik
değil
yani örneğin
önce burayı
bir tekrar
edelim
şimdi bakın
1-2-4-3
şimdi
tekrar
çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi
1-2-4-3
değil de
başka bir
sıralama
olabilir mi
cevap
tabii ki
tekrar
çalıştırıyorum
arkadaşlar
4-1-2-3
tekrar
çalıştırıyorum
1-4-2-3
şimdi
geliyorum
ikinci noktaya
arkadaşlar
bakın
Constructor
içinde
oluşan
yazılara
bakın
Dispointer'ı
hepsi için
farklı
çünkü
MyClass
nesnelere
eğer
hepsi
aynı
nesneyi
kullanıyor
olsaydı
Mehmet Ali
o zaman
ne olacaktı
aynı
adres
olacaktı
bir şeye
daha dikkat edin
bu da
çok önemli
bakın
şimdi
burada
Destructor'lar
çağrıldı
ve önce
Constructor'lar
içindeki yazıyı
gördük
sonra Destructor'lar
içindeki yazıyı
gördük
ama şimdi
birkaç kere
daha çalıştırayım
her birinde
aynı şekilde
olmayacak
bir yakalayabiliriz
bakın
şimdi bakın
çok güzel gösteriyor
durumu
arkadaşlar
öyle bir durum
oluştu ki
bakın
funcint
cold
yazısı
çıktı
fakat ondan sonra
MyClass
Constructor
ilk seçittir
bir
arkadaşlar
bu yazı
çıktı
sonra bu
Destructor'ı
oldu
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
çünkü
threadlerin çalışması
sona erdiğinde
Destructor
çağrılacak
Thread
local
değişkeni için
bakın
ilk Destructor
burada
çağrıldı
işte görüyorsunuz
F4 adresi
yani burada
thread çalışmaya
başlamış
MyClass
nesnesinin
Constructor'ı
çağrılmış
Thread local
değişkeninin
adresi bu
ama
bu thread'in
çalışması
burada bitmiş ki
bu nesne için
Destructor
çağrılmış
aynı şekilde
burada
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
0-4
yazısı var
ama onun
Destructor'ı
burada
çağrılmış
anlaşıldı mı
evet
birkaç örnek
daha
temalar
hep aynı
ama
bir iki tane
kritik noktayı
daha gösterelim
yine burada
bu sefer
Blockscope'da
değil
Namespace
Scope'da
thread local
değişken var
Alian Bozkır diyor ki
non-deterministik olduğu için
Constructor sırasının
ters sırasıyla
Destructor çağrılmıyor
değil mi?
Tam soruyu
anlayamamış
olabilirim
ama
şöyle diyelim
hangi nesnenin
daha önce
Constructor olacağı
garanti altında
değil
evet o da
deterministik değil
dolayısıyla
şimdi bakın
buradaki
fung fonksiyonu
thread'in
ID'sini
görebilmemiz için
Charter'den
bir parametreye
sahip
ve arkadaşlar
thread local
değişkeni
arttırıyorum
artı artı
operatörüyle
ve 11.
satırda
hem
C karakterinin
aynı karakteri
olduğunu
ayrıca
bir de
thread local
değişkenin
arkadaşlar
değerini
yazdırıyorum
şimdi
16.
satırda
bir
C thread
vektörü
oluşturdum
ve bu
vektöre
A dahil
Z dahil
A'dan Z'ye
az gidebiliyorsunuz
bu karakterler
artışık
bütün karakterleri
emplacement fonksiyonunun
ikinci parametresine
argüman olarak
geçtim ve
birinci parametresine
doğal olarak
fonksiyonun
adresine
geçtim
yine burada
ne göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
aslında
burada
yazdırılan
değer
hep
bir olacak
yani
her karakter için
bir olacak
çünkü
26 tane
park karakteri
var
26 tane
thread oluşturmuş
oluyorum
thread'te de
arkadaşlar
her birinin
GT
isimli değişkeni
ayrı değişken
thread'e özgü
dolayısıyla
hepsinin
değeri bir olacak
bakın şimdi
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
bu arada
yine
deterministik olmadığını
görüyorsunuz
bakın
aslında döngüde
ilk önce
A var
sonra B
sonra C
ama ilk çalıştırılan
thread'te
A
B
sonra S
sonra C
sonra G
sonra H
ama tabii ki
bütün harfler için
burada bir ekran
çıktısı var
şimdi yine
kodu değiştirelim
int GT'yi
global değişken
yapalım
fakat
burada
data race
oluşmaması
için
artı artı
GT'yi
critical
section
bu terimin
anlamını
açıklayacağım
yani birden fazla
thread'in
aynı kaynağı
kullandığı
kod kısmına
arkadaşlar
ne deniyor
critical section
şimdi critical section'ı
Emirhan Bey'in dediği gibi
bir mutex ile
koruyalım
az önce
ben
log card
ray sınıfını
kullanmıştım
şimdi
log card'ın
ne yaptığını da
daha iyi göreceğiz
aslında
bir
stup mutex
nesnesi alıyorum
ve
burada
mtx
log fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
herhangi bir
thread
buraya girdiğinde
log fonksiyonu
çağrılacak
eğer
burada
mutex
serbest durumdaysa
buraya gelen
thread
mutex'i
tabiriyle
ingilizce
log edecek
kilitleyecek
böylece
öbür
thread'ler
buraya geldiğinde
beklemek
zorunda kalacak
onlar
bekleyecekler
ta ki
ne zamana
kadar
buraya gelen
thread
bu kritik bölgeden
çıkıp
örneğin bu
noktada
mutex'in
unlock
fonksiyonu
çağrıldığı
zaman
böylece
arkadaşlar
buradaki
kodun
birden fazla
thread'in
bu kodu
aynı zamanda
yürütme
ihtimali
ortadan
kalkacak
arkadaşlar
data race
race
condition
arasındaki
farka da
dikkat
şimdi
soru
bu şekilde
mutual
exclusion
ile
ben
data race
önledim mi
cevap
evet
önledim
tabii ki
ama
burada
race
condition
var mı
yani
race
condition
aslında var
şu anlamda
kullanıyorsak
aynı değişken
kullanılıyor
ama burada
deterministik
değil
mesela
siz bu
fonksiyonun
mantığını
buraya dikkat
siz bu
fonksiyonun
mantığını
önce
a
thread'i
buraya girecek
sonra
b thread'i
girecek
buna göre
oluşturmuşsanız
mesela
b için
çağrılan
thread
a thread'inin
dikkat
oluşturduğu
bir sonuçtan
faydalanıyorsa
buradaki
race
condition
programınızı
undifferent
behavior
yapmayacak
ama lojik
yapısını
değiştirecek
burayı anladık
değil mi
data race
doğrudan
tanımsız
davranış
yani burada
örneğin
mutex
koruma
yapmasaydım
data race
olacaktı
ve undefined
behavior
olacaktı
ama
şimdi
buradaki
kodun
ne olduğuna
bağlı
olarak
örneğin
buradaki
kod
bir thread
tarafından
bir değişkeni
değiştiriyorsa
sonra
başka bir
thread
o değişkeni
kullanıyorsa
o zaman
hangi
thread'in
bu noktaya
daha önce
geleceğine
bağlı olarak
değer
kullandıkları
farklı olacak
burada bir
race
condition var
ama
İngilizcesiyle
race
condition
terimin anlamını
biliyorsunuz
değil mi
benign
hani
tümörler
Allah göstermesin
tümörler için
kullanılıyor ya
iyi huylu
kötü huylu
orada iyi huylu
derken
kullanılan
terim
ben de
nasıl
uğursuz
bir örnek
verdim
evet
arkadaşlar
yani
tanımsız
davranış
oluşturmuyor
ama
race
condition
olması
sizin
programınızın
lojik
yapısının
doğru olduğu
anlamına
da gelmiyor
eğer o
race
condition
etkilenmeyen
bir lojik
yapıya
sahipse
bir problem
yok
etkileniyorsa
tanımsız
davranış yok
ama
diyelim ki
hangi
thread'in
ne noktada
nerede
olduğuna
bağlı olarak
programın
akışı
farklı
değerlerle
devam
edebilir
evet
şimdi
korumayı
yaptık
bir problem
yok
ve bakın
şimdi
tamamen
programın
akışı
değişecek
şimdi
bakın
arkadaşlar
e için
çağrılmış
değişkenin
değerinin
2 olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
burada
belki
aklınıza
şöyle bir şey
gelebilir
ilk başta
necati
ilk çağrılıyorsa
bunun 1
bunun 2
bunun 3
olması
gerekmiyor
tabii ki
bu da
deterministik
değil
çünkü bu
fonksiyonun
kodunda
nerede
olduğumuza
bağlı
yani
örneğin
bir fonksiyon
bunun
değerini
değiştirdi
sonra
başka bir
fonksiyon
onun
değerini
örneğin
okudu
arkadaşlar
hatta
şöyle de
gösterelim
sıranın
evet
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
B1
bakın
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 10 11 11 12 24 25 26 düzeldi ama eğer unlock'u buraya alsaydım buradaki yazım tamamen non deterministik hale gelecekti. Emrehan Çelik ama değer arttırımı deterministik birbirinden nasıl haberleri var?
birbirinden haberleri yok. Birbirinden haberi olduğu sonucuna nasıl vardık? Aynı değişken farklı threadler tarafından belirli zaman noktalarında değiştiriliyor.
Şimdi o aslında yine mutual exclusion'un konusu soru biraz daha derin. Şöyle söyleyelim. Buradaki senkronizasyon buraya dikkat. Buradaki unlock fonksiyonun çağrılmasından sonra
kritik bölgede yapılan değişikliklerin diğer threadler tarafından görülebilir olması garantisini veriyor. Bakın tekrar söylüyorum. İlerleyen haftalarda dersimiz konusu olacak. Buradaki unlock fonksiyonun çağrısı artık bu kritik bölgede yapılan değişikliklerin diğer threadler tarafından görülebilir olma garantisini veriyor.
Buradaki semantik yapıya ileride acquire release semantiği dendiğini öğreneceğiz. Acquire release semantiği. İşte mutual exclusion burada acquire release semantiğini ne yapıyor? Garanti altına alıyor.
Evet. Peki devam arkadaşlar. Bakın şimdi çok güzel bir soru sormuştu. Nerede kullanacağız diye. Bakın rastgele sayı üretimi çok güzel bir örnek.
Şimdi soru. Bir fonksiyon var. Bir fonksiyon rastgele sayı üretecek ve o fonksiyon içinde üretilecek rastgele sayılar kullanılacak.
Şimdi her thread için a. Üretilen rastgele sayıların farklı farklı fuhum değerleriyle oluşturulan zincirden elde edilmesini istiyorsunuz.
B. Her thread'te o fonksiyon koştuğunda o thread'in de aynı rastgele sayıları üretmesini istiyorsunuz.
Burada soruyu anladınız mı? Burada çok tipik bir tema.
Bakın şimdi. Random başlık dosyasını bir ekleyelim. Bu örnek bence çok çok önemli.
Ve stud MT 19 937 türünden bir değişken tanımlayalım. Hatta doğrudan bir tohum değeri verelim.
Arkadaşlar. 612 321 U.
Şimdi soru. Bu thread local mı yoksa statik mi?
Cevap şu anda statik.
Eğer buraya thread local key word'ünü koysaydım thread local uzaktı.
Peki devam.
Bunun thread local olması ya da statik olması neyi değiştiriyor?
Statik olursa bunu kullanan fonksiyonu koşturan her thread aynı nesneyi kullanacak.
O nesne bir kez konstrakt olacak ama rastgele sayı üretimi o tohumun zincirini devam ettirecek.
Yani hangi thread'te rastgele sayı üretilirse aslında bu enjinin bir sonraki rastgele sayısını üretecek.
Buraya kadar takip edebildiniz mi?
Evet.
Şimdi söz konusu fonksiyonu da bu olsun.
Bu.
İzleyin.
Burada bir uniform int distribution nesnesi oluşturayım.
Diyelim ki 10 dahil.
99 dahil.
Ve burada yine hatırlatalım ki uniform int distribution da aslında jenerik bir sınıf.
Burada a böyle yazsaydım template argümanının int olduğunu belirtecektim.
B böyle yazsaydım bu sefer de default template argümanı int olacaktı.
Çünkü default template argümanına sahip.
Ve böyle yazsaydım da sitatla template argümanının int seçildiği anlaşılacaktı.
Şimdi burada 10 kez dönen bir döngü oluşturalım.
Döngünün her durumda.
Iostream başlık dosyasını da dahil ediyorum.
Ve üretilen rastgele sayıyı yazdırıyorum.
Stud.
See out.
Arkadaşlar.
Dist.
Enge.
Hatırlıyorsunuz bu konuyu.
Ve bir de boşluk karakteri yazsın.
Evet şimdi main fonksiyonunu yazalım.
Main fonksiyonu is in thread
t1
to thread
ve
u
Buraya dikkat.
Şimdi bu join etsin.
t1 join
Arkadaşlar.
İkinci bir thread oluşturuyorum.
t2
Hatta join ettikten sonra bir de nimline verelim.
Ondan sonra ikinci bir thread oluşturalım.
Bunu da join edelim.
Arkadaşlar.
Ve bir nimline daha verelim.
Üçüncü bir thread oluşturalım.
t3
Join
ve nimline.
Evet şimdi
dikkatli izliyoruz.
Arkadaşlar.
Buradaki nesne
global bir nesne.
Dolayısıyla
statik ömürlü.
Statik ömürlü olduğu için
bu bir kere hayata gelecek.
Böylece ilk thread
ilk rastgele sayı zincirinin
ilk 10 sayısını kullanacak.
İkinci thread ondan sonraki 10 sayısını
üçüncü thread ondan sonraki 10 sayısını kullanacak.
Bu durumda
oluşturulan threadler
aynı rastgele sayıları
kullanmıyor olacak değil mi?
sayılar tamamen farklı.
Tekrar çalıştırıyorum.
Sayılar
farklı.
Ama şimdi
bunu
thread local yaparsam
arkadaşlar
artık
her thread için
ayrı bir
mt19937 nesnesi var.
ama her thread için
oluşan bu
mt19937 nesneleri
arkadaşlar
aynı tohum değeriyle
başladığı için
aynı rastgele sayıları
üretecek.
Dolayısıyla şimdi
ne değişti?
Evet
bir tane değil
üç tane rastgele sayı
üreticisi
enjinin var.
Ama üçü de
aynı tohum değerini
kullandığı için
aynı rastgele sayıları
üretecek.
takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Aradaki farkı
gördük mü?
Şimdi
bir değişiklik
daha yapalım.
Eğer bu
thread local
olmasaydı
fakat ben bu
threadleri
birlikte
koştursaydım
yani
örneğin
c thread
t1
t2
t3
arkadaşlar
t4
ve t5
önce ilk yorumunuzu
alayım.
Sizce bu programda
bir
ne diyelim
hata var mı
yok mu
tanımsız davranış var mı
bravo Mehmet Ali
tanımsız.
Neden
tanımsız?
çünkü
data race var.
MT19937
türünden
ENG'de
shared resource
dolayısıyla
onun kullanıldığı yerde
onu
korumam
senkronize etmem
gerekecek.
Yani bu kodda
bir kere
data race var
bu kod güvenli
değil.
iki
arkadaşlar
eğer
data race'e karşı
önlem almak istiyorsam
bakın bu
otomatik ömürlü
nesne
bunu korumam
gerekmiyor
ama
hem buradaki
see out'u
hem de buradaki
arkadaşlar
ENG'yi
birden fazla
türe çalıştıracağı için
race condition
olduğu için
o zaman
burada
mutual exclusion
sağlamalıyım.
işte
onu da şöyle
sağlayalım
stud mutex
mtx
mutex ayrı bir
başlık dosyasında
ve şimdi
kritik bölge
şu kod
ve bu kodda
korumaya alalım.
Ya şöyle yazacağız
mtx'in
lakı
an lakı
ya da
buraya dikkat
şimdi bunu
yazmanın
sakıncasının
ne olduğunu
tahmin edebiliyor
musunuz?
Henüz görmedik ama
arkadaşlar
lakla
an lak arasında
bir exception
trove ederse
ne olur?
Felaket olur.
Neden felaket olur?
Çünkü
o exception
yakalansa
dahi
evet
ama hatayı
tam açıklayalım
o exception
yakalansa
dahi
an lak
çağrılmayacağı
için
burada
normalde
buraya
diyelim ki
gelen
ikinci
thread
an lakı
bekleyecek
dolayısıyla
an lak edilmediği
için
burada
artık o
threadin
ilerlemesi
duracak.
İşte böyle
durum
bu yine
neyin tipik bir
örneği?
Ne deniyordu
bu duruma?
Ölü kilit
deadlock
oluşacak
anlaşıldı
değil mi?
Ama
şimdi
bunu
nasıl
tamir ediyoruz?
Öyle bir sınıf
olsun ki
işte böyle
sınıflara
rayı sınıfı
deniyor.
Öyle bir sınıf
olsun ki
o sınıf
türünden
bir nesne
bir kilidi
sarmalasın
bir mutex'i
konstruktörıyla
mutex'i
lak etsin
yani
kitlesin
ama
destruktör'ı
çağrıldığında
da
destruktör'ı
mutex'i
unlock
etsin.
Böylece
artık
tekrar tekrar
söylemiyorum
rayı
temasını
ne şekilde
koddan
çıkarsa
çıksın
ya
skopunun
sonunda
ya da
stack unwinding
sürecinde
otomatik ömürlü
yerel sınıf
nesnesi için
destruktör çağrılacak
ve çağrılan
destruktör'da
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak.
Böylece
deadlock
oluşmayacak.
Arkadaşlar
şimdilik
ben örneklerde
ben şimdilik
örneklerde
lock ve
unlock
fonksiyonlarında
kendim
çağırıyorum
ama üretimde
asla
bunu
yapmam
çünkü
bu
deadlock'a
davetiye
çıkartır.
Alian Bozkır
lock ve
unlock ile
istediğimiz
aralığı
verebiliyoruz
değil mi?
Çok güzel bir
soru.
Alian
bravo.
diyor ki
ben diyor
herhangi bir
sarmalayıcı
sınıf
kullanmadan
burada
örneğin
burayı
kritik bölgeye
alıp
buradaki
kodun
kritik bölgede
olmasını
engelleyebilirim.
Dolayısıyla
kritik bölgeyi
istediğim kadar
dar
geniş
tutabilirim.
Ama peki
lock card'ı
kullandığımda
bu nasıl olacak?
Son derece
basit.
İşte
nested block
oluşturacağız.
o zaman da
şöyle bakın
daha önce bir
derste
ben
bir kontrol
deyimi olmadan
nested block
oluşturmakta
çok iyi
aygın
C++'da
demiştim.
Yani bu
aslında
bize şimdi
çok tuhaf
yeni tanışanlara
geliyor ama
tamamen onu
uygulayayım.
Bakın
Alian
burada
lock card
nesnesini
oluşturuyorum.
Lock
card
spot
lock
card
guard
ve
mutex'i
constructor'ına
alıyor.
Şimdi
çok dikkatli
izleyin.
Eğer böyle
yazarsam
burada da
başka kodlar
olsun
bir sürü
kod olsun
arkadaşlar
bu kodların
hepsi
koruma altında
korumadan
neyi kastettiğimi
anlıyorsunuz
kilit altında
çalışacak.
Yani artık
burada
herhangi bir şekilde
bir data
riski
olmayacak.
ama
Alian diyor ki
ben
şurayla
sınırlı
tutmak
isteseydim
bu kodların
çalışmasından
önce
burada
mutex'in
unlock
fonksiyonunu
çağırırdım.
Şimdi ne yapacağım?
Ben de bunu
çok sık
uygularım zaten.
Bakın
şöyle yapacaksınız.
Bu da çok
idiomatik bir yapı
yani
çok enteresan
bir şey değil.
Şimdi
ne değişti
Alian?
Buradaki
otomatik
ömürlü
nesne
olan
card'ın
destraktarı
bu
blok
skopta
olduğu için
skopunun
sonunda
burada
çağrılacak
ve burada
kilit
unlock
edilecek.
Zaten
arkadaşlar
mülakatlarda
falan da
sorulan
en tipik
sorulardan
biri
şimdi
en çok
yapılan
hatalardan
biri ne
biliyor musunuz?
Kritik
bölgeyi
İngilizce
critical
section
deniyor.
Yani
mutual
explosion
ile
korunan
kod alanını
gerekenden
çok daha
geniş
tutmak.
Gerekenden
geniş
tutmak.
şurada
bir blok
eksik
kalmış.
Ben
göstermek
için
yazdım.
Teşekkür
ederim
Olsan.
Bu durumda
maliyet
artıyor.
Çünkü
bakın
o kilitin
edinilmesi
tekrar
bırakılması
bu
öbür
threadlerden
bekleyen
birinin
alması
bu
maliyetli
runtime'da
çalışan
kod var
bunlar için.
Dolayısıyla
birçok
kodda
ben bu
hatayı
görüyorum.
Mesela
gitmiş
komple
kod alanını
mutex
altında
çalıştırmış.
Aslında
mesela
orada otomatik
ömürlü
nesneler
kullanılıyor.
Mutex'e
gerek var mı?
Yok.
Bazen de
şöyle oluyor
tipik hata
inşallah
ilerleyen derslerde
onlara
örnekler de
oluştururum.
Bazen de
şöyle bir
hata
yapılıyor.
Evet evet
kritik bölgeye
almak
gerekiyor.
Ama
şöyle bir
imkan da var
programca o
imkanın
farkında
değil.
Aslında
önce işlemleri
yerel
otomatik
ömürlü
değişkenlerle
yapıp
sonucu
elde
ettikten
sonra
eğer o
değer
threadle
kullanılacaksa
sadece
o zaman
mutex'i
kullanmak.
Yani
eğer
oradaki
kod
örneğin
bir değer
hesaplamaya
yönelikse
o değeri
hesaplama
sürecinin
hepsinin
gidip de
ne olmasına
gerek yok?
Kritik bölge
olmasına
gerek yok.
Hesaplamayı
otomatik
ömürlü
yerel
değişkenlerle
yapıyorsanız
onlar bırakın
öyle çalışsın.
Ama ne zaman
koruma
gerekiyorsa
otomatik
ömürlü
yerel
değişkenden
orada
aktarın
paylaşılan
değişkeni.
Alihan
Bozkır
kritik
bölgedeki
değişkenlerin
ömrüde
otomatik
olmadığı
için
ömürlerinin
bitmesi
de
söz
konusu
olmuyor
değil mi?
Tam
anlayamadım
ama
sanırım
şunu
soruyorsunuz
ayrı
kritik
bölge
mesela
buradaki
değişken
otomatik
ömürlü
bir değişken
mi?
Tabii ki.
Burayı
anladık mı?
Bu otomatik
ömürlü
bir değişken.
Anlaşıldı
mı?
Evet.
Yani
kritik
bölgedeki
değişkenlerin
de ömrü
yine orada
bitiyor
mu?
Tabii ki.
Mesela
burada
ben
arkadaşlar
bir
değişken
oluştursam
T
türünden
X
yine
daha önce
öğrendiğimiz
gibi
programın
akışı
bu bloğa
geldiğinde
hayata
gelecek
burada
bunun hayatı
bitecek
anlaşıldı
mı?
Evet.
Ama
şunu
söylemek
istiyorum
otomatik
ömürlü
değişken
için
bir
mütex'e
ihtiyacımız
yok.
Burada
örneğin
mütex
kullanmamın
tek nedeni
ya da
iki nedeni
diyelim
Siyah
alt nesnesinin
paylaşımlı
olması
olarak
threadler
tarafından
kullanılması
ve
aynı zamanda
bakın
DIST'in değil
DIST'e otomatik
ömürlü
değişken
ama
buradaki
ENG
isimli
MT19937
nesnesinin
global bir
değişken olduğu için
paylaşımlı
kullanılıyor
olması.
evet
peki
şimdi
devam edelim
arkadaşlar
yavaş yavaş
konuyu
değiştireceğiz
mesela
bakın
biraz daha
üretime
sözde
yakın
bir örnek
şimdi
kullanıldığı
yerleri
neresi
olabilir
dedik ya
ya da
kim demişti
Alihan Bey
demişti
şimdi ona
güzel bir cevap
Bakın şimdi
Database Connection
isimli
bir sınıf
var
işte
adı üstünde
veri tabanı
bağlantısı
yani
Database Connection
sınıfı
türünden
bir nesne
oluşturduğumuzda
bir veri tabanına
bağlantı
oluşturmuş
oluyoruz
arkadaşlar
e şimdi
birden fazla
thread
ayrı ayrı
veri tabanından
sorgulama
yapacaksa
burada
her biri için
ayrı bir
bağlantı
olmasını
istiyorum
yani
buradaki
worker
isimli
fonksiyona
bakın
yine
parametresi
suni bir
şekilde
hangi
thread'in
worker'ı
çalıştırdığını
göstermeye
yönelik
intörden bir
parametre
değişkeni
var
ama sözde
36.
ve 37.
satırdaki
kodlar
ilgili
database'de
bir sorgulama
yapıyor
işte burada
uydurduğum
ismini
execute
query
diye bir
fonksiyon
var
işte
bir
SQL
komutu
olduğunu
düşünün
select'i
kullanıyor
efendim
alttaki de
update'i
kullanıyor
şimdi
birden fazla
thread
aynı
veri tabanı
bağlantısını
kullanması
başka
her thread'in
ayrı bir
veri tabanı
bağlantısı
kurması
başka
öyle değil mi
şimdi ben
her thread'in
ayrı bir
veri tabanı
bağlantısı
oluşturması
için
burada
database
connection
türünden
db
connection
isimli
değişkeni
thread local
yaptım
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
ve
main
fonksiyonu
içinde
yine
dört tane
thread'i
koyduğum
bir
c-thread
vektörü
oluşturdum
ve
vektörü
oluştururken
işte burada
döngü
değişkeninin
değerini de
thread
id olarak
fonksiyona
gönderdim
hatta
sıfırda
yazmasın
en az
bir olsun
şimdi
programı
değerleyip
çalıştırıyorum
evet
bakın şimdi
aslında
dört tane
ayrı
thread var
bunlar
thread
id
fonksiyonu
izleyin
yani
get
id
fonksiyonunun
verdiği
değer
thread
database
connection
established
veri tabanı
bağlantısı
yapıldı
ama
başka bir
thread için
o da ayrı
bir veri tabanı
bağlantısı
yapıyor
değil mi
bakın
database
connection
established
database
connection
established
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
her biri
ayrı bir veri tabanı
bağlantısı
oluşturuyor
çünkü her
thread'in
database
connection
türünden
değişkeni
o thread'e
özgü
şimdi
eğer
bu
global
olsaydı
o zaman
her thread
aynı değişkeni
kullanacaktı
aynı
bağlantı
altında
thread'ler
sorgulama
yapacaktı
tabi o zaman
da
ona yönelik
kod
arkadaşlar
bir
mutual
exclusion
gerektirecekti
şimdi
burada
neden
thread
local
değişken
kullanıyoruz
sorusunun
cevaplarından
biri de
şüphesiz
eğer
thread local
değişken
kullanmasak
birçok
senaryoda
mutual
exclusion
kullanacağım
ve o da
maliyeti
ciddi bir
şekilde
ne yapacak
arttıracak
efendim
şimdi
konuyu değiştiriyoruz
önemli bir
öğeyle
daha tanışacağız
arkadaşlar
şimdi
multi-thread
programlamada
çok karşımıza
çıkan
şöyle bir
tema var
bir kod
birden fazla
thread tarafından
çalıştırıldığında
ya da
bir
callable
birden fazla
thread tarafından
çalıştırılsa da
belirli bir
kodun
sadece
bir kere
yürütülmesini
istiyoruz
mesela
düşünün
arkadaşlar
efendim
10 tane
thread çalıştırıyor
ama
bu threadlerin
çalıştırdığı
kodda
bir nesnenin
initialize edilmesi
gerekiyor
ama
bütün threadler
aynı nesneyi
kullanacak
ama onun
bir kere
initialize edilmesi
gerekiyor
mesela
singleton'da
çok tipik
bir tema
bu değil mi
singleton
patternini
örüntüsünü
hatırlayın
bir sınıf
türünden
tek bir nesne
olacak
ve ona
global bir
erişim
akses sağlayacağız
o zaman
tek bir nesne
oluşumunu
sağlamak için
arkadaşlar
bir önlem
almam lazım
thread safe
olması için
eğer önlem
almazsam
onun
singleton'lığı
kalmaz
ama bu
sadece
singleton için
geçerli bir
tema değil
bir kodun
birden fazla
thread
aynı kodu
çalıştırmasına
rağmen
kodun
belirli bir
kısmının
sadece
bir kez
çalışmasını
yani örneğin
oraya ilk
giren
thread tarafından
çalıştırılmasını
ama daha
sonraki
threadlerin
o kodu
bir daha
çalıştırmamasını
istiyorsunuz
işte arkadaşlar
bunu sağlamaya
yönelik
çok güzel
bir araç
var
burada
iki tane
araç var
diyelim
bir tanesi
once flag
isimli
bir tür
örnekler
vereceğim
diğeri de
whole
once isimli
bir
fonksiyon
o zaman
aslında
konumuz ne
bir
bunlar birbiriyle
ilişkili
kullanacak
once flag
bu türün
ismi
arkadaşlar
ikincisi de
whole
once
şimdi
önce
syntax'a girmeden
genel mantığını
alalım
arkadaşlar
whole
once
fonksiyonu
parametre olarak
bir once flag
alacak
ve diğer
parametre olarak
da
çalıştıracağı
callable
alacak
aynı
once flag
değişkenini
kullanan
kodda
o
call
once'a
argüman
olarak
gönderilen
callable
sadece
bir kez
çalıştırılacak
yani
sizin
tek
yapmanız
gereken
bu durumda
ne
bir tane
once flag
değişkeni
alacaksınız
ve
thread içinde
whole
once
fonksiyonuna
argüman
olarak
eğer o
bir kere
çalıştırılmasını
istediğiniz
kod için
whole
once
fonksiyonuna
argüman
olarak
o
once
flag'i
geçeceksiniz
ikinci
parametreye
de o
kodu
çalıştıracak
callable
geçeceksiniz
bakın
şimdi
çok tipik
bir örnek
ama
örnek
biraz
karnışık
olabilir
birlikte
kurgulayacağız
mesela
burada
bir tane
nesne
olsa
stud
unique
ptr
herhangi bir
açılımı
int açılımı
updr
şimdi
şöyle bir senaryo
kuralım
birden fazla
thread
bu
unique
ptr
nesnesini
kullanacak
ama
unique
ptr'ında
initialize
edilmesi
gerekiyor
unique
ptr'ı
hatırlayın
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
ya da
kaynağın
ömrünü
kontrol edecek
dolayısıyla
bütün threadlerin
aynı
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
kullanmasını
istiyorum
ama
ilk çalışan
thread
ne yapacak
unique ptr
nesnesini
nesnesinin
dinamik ömürlü
bir int nesneyi
göstermesini
sağlayacak
diğer threadler
o nesneyi
kullanacak
bunu sağlamak
istiyorum
şimdi ben
şöyle bir
kod yazsam
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
void
foo
ve desem ki
işte burada
uptr
eşittir
stud
make
unique
efendim
int açılımı
hatırlıyorsunuz
make unique'i
değil mi
efendim
örneğin
şimdi
foo fonksiyonu
birden fazla
thread tarafından
çalıştırıldığında
o zaman
her thread'in
çalışmasında
kod buraya
geldiğinde
aynı
uptr'ye
bu sefer
farklı bir
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
adresini
yerleştirecek
değil mi
buraya takip
edebildik mi
evet
ama bu benim
istediğim bir şey
değil
bu kodun
bir kere
çalışmasını
istiyorum
temayı
anladığınızdan
emin misiniz
tamam
şimdi bunun için
ne yapıyoruz
bakın
şu kodun
bir kere
çalışması için
ne yapıyoruz
gidiyorum
aslında yapmak
istediğim şu
izleyin
yapmak istediğim şu
çalıştırılacak
bir fonksiyon
olsun
mesela bakın
bu fonksiyon
void
herhangi bir fonksiyon
ask
thread'in çalıştıracağı
fonksiyon bu olsun
hatta tersi demeyelim
word load
diyelim
ve thread'in çalıştıracağı
fonksiyon
diyelim ki
burada da
get value
isimli bir fonksiyon
olsun
ve get value
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
geri dönüş
değeri
constant
rep
olsun
aslında
return
yıldız
ptr
uptr
uptr'nin gösterdiği
nesneyi
referans semantiğiyle
döndürsün
buraya kadar takip
edebildik mi
evet
ama bunu yapabilmesi
için
uptr'nin
initialize edilmesi
gerekiyor
burada
uptr'nin
init edilme garantisi
olması lazım
init edilmiş
olma
garantisi
gerekiyor
bu bir
ama
init işleminin
tek bir thread
tarafından yapılması
yapılması
gerekiyor
şimdi bakın
bunu nasıl
sağlıyorum
ama
senaryoya geçmeden
test kodumuzu da
oluşturalım
test kodumuzda
main fonksiyonu
içinde
bu word load
yukarıdaki
get value'yu
çağırayım
get value
ve
bunu bir
referans
değişkende
kutayım
host
int rep
hani referans
değişkene
bağlayayım
arkadaşlar
ve
şuraya da bir
assertion
koyalım
include
c
assert
ne olduğundan
emin olmamız
gerekiyor
assert
değişkenimin
değeri
yani
v'nin
değeri
re'nin
eşit
arkadaşlar
olması
gerekiyor
eğer bu
assertion
fail
olursa
demek ki
bir yanlışlık
var
şimdi
main fonksiyonu
içinde
vektör
başlık
dosyasını
da dahil
edelim
ve yine
diyelim ki
20 tane
thread
oluşturalım
arkadaşlar
vektörün
c thread
açılımı
thread
başlık
dosyası
örnek
biraz
karmaşık
gelebilir
üstünden
bir daha
geçeriz
vektörün
c thread
açılımı
türünden
thread
vektörü
arkadaşlar
pvek
reserve
fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
16 ya da
20 olsun
20 tane
threadlik
yeri
allocate etsin
thread nesnesi
için
şimdi
vektörü
dolaşıyorum
arkadaşlar
daha doğrusu
20 kez
dönen bir
döngü
oluşturuyorum
ve
emplaceback
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
tvekin
emplaceback
yukarıdaki
arkadaşlar
workload
fonksiyonu
takip edebildik mi
buraya kadar
süper
et c thread
olduğu için
artık
join fonksiyonlarını
çağırmıyorum
evet
şimdi
bu garantiyi
nasıl elde edeceğiz
yani
UPTR'nin
bir kez
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
adresini
tutmasını
ama
20 tane
thread full
fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ona rağmen
bir tane
dinamik ömürlü
değerinde
nesne
oluşmasını
nasıl
sağlayacağız
işte burada
kullandığımız
öğe
ya da
kullanacağımız
öğe
iki tane
biri
neydi
once flag
türünden
bir değişken
ki bu değişkeni
call once
fonksiyonuna
birinci parametresine
argüman olarak
göndermem
gerekiyor
arkadaşlar
bakın ne
yapıyorum
şimdi get value
fonksiyonu
burada değil mi
bunun
bir kez
init edilmiş olma
garantisini
sağlamak için
burada
arkadaşlar
call once
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
stud
call
once
bir şey dikkat edin
call once
fonksiyonunun
birinci parametresi
referans
semantiğiyle
once flag
alıyor
diğer parametresi
de aslında
neyi alıyor
arkadaşlar
call
bunu alıyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
ama şimdi o zaman
benim
şu
uptr'ye
dinamik ömürlü
bir nesnenin
adresini
verecek kodu
bir kere
oluşturmam
lazım
değil mi
işte onu
burada
neyle yapacağım
arkadaşlar
şu fonksiyonun
ismine
init
diyeyim
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ve
hatta şöyle
f
init
diyeyim
f
init fonksiyonu
içinde
aslında şu konu olsun
uptr eşittir
arkadaşlar
makeunic
int
şimdi tek yapmam
gereken ne
burada
aslında
init fonksiyonunun
bir kez çağrılmasını
sağlamak
onu da nasıl yapıyorum
for once'ın
parametresine bir
bütün
tracklerin erişe
once flag
geçmem gerekiyor
işte onu da
global
minis ne yapayım
stut
once
flag
arkadaşlar
init flag
artık herhangi bir
izin verebilirsiniz
ve
call
once'ın
birinci parametresine
init flag'i
ikinci parametresine
arkadaşlar
çağrılacak
global'ı
geçtim
bu kadar
şimdi artık
hangi garanti
elde ettim
buradaki
get value
fonksiyonu
50 tane
thread'den
çalıştırılsa
dahi
buradaki
infinite
fonksiyonu
bir kez
çağrılacak
derken
dikkat
tabi ki
ilk
get value'yu
çalıştıracak
fonksiyon
bu noktaya
geldiğinde
o fonksiyonu
init
infinite
çalışacak
ikinci
thread buraya
geldiğinde
artık o
infinite
fonksiyonu
tekrar
çağrılmayacak
yani
call once'la
belirlenen
call
ball'ın
bir kez
çalışmasını
sağlıyorum
burada
tabi ki
söz konusu
call once
çağrısındaki
init
flag
bütün
thread'ler için
aynı değişken
olmak zorunda
efendim
şimdi
eksik bir şey
kaldı mı
bakalım
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
necati bir şey
olmadı
ya zaten
bir şey
olmaması
gerekiyor
bir şey
olsaydı
bu
assertion
arkadaşlar
fail
olacaktı
e şimdi
biraz daha
temayı
değiştirelim
arkadaşlar
izleyin
çok daha
basit bir örnek
üstünden
göstereceğim
şimdi
oradan
yazdığım
kodu
yapıştıracağım
her sene
önce
arkadaşlar
şimdi
konuyu
çok daha
basit şekilde
gösteren
yine bir örnek
sadece şunu
görmenizi
istiyorum
şurada
call once
çağrısı var
değil mi
cevap
evet
call once
çağrısına
argüman
olarak
hangi
kolum
geçilmiş
şu
lambda
expression
yani
lambda
expression
demek
oradaki
closure
object
demek
o zaman
buradaki
call once
bu fonksiyonun
yani bu
lambda
function'ın
bir kez
çalıştırılmasını
sağlayacak
değil mi
ama şimdi
espriye
bakın
punk'ın
birden fazla
thread tarafından
çalıştırıldığını
göstermek için
bir parametre koydum
id parametresi
ve
call once'ın
çağrılmasında
bu
ne diyelim
şuradaki
lambda
function'ı
çağıran
thread'in
id'sini
göreceğiz
burada
çünkü bakın
id'yi
yazdırıyorum
burada
ne olacağını
anlıyor musunuz
ben diyelim ki
16 tane
thread oluştursam
20 tane
bu
bir kere
çalıştırılacak
ama
tabii ki
hangi
thread'in
bu fonksiyonu
ilk olarak
çağrıldığı
deterministik
değil adeta
piyango gibi
biz bir çalıştırdığımızda
diyelim ki
12 göreceğiz
bir çalıştırdığımızda
20 göreceğiz
ben
16 için
16 tane
thread nesnesi için
bellek alanını
rezerv ettim ama
12 tane nesne
oluşturdum
pekala bu
16 da olabilirdi
izleyin
bakın
7 no'lu
id'yi
çalıştırır
yani buradaki
thread'lerden
thread id'si
7 olan
şimdi
yine
görüyorsunuz
değişik
ama
eğer bu
birden fazla
kez
çalıştırılsaydı
o zaman
biz ekranda
bu yazıdan
iki tane
görürdük
bir tane
gördüğümüze göre
bir kez çalıştırıldı
garanti altında
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi şu örneğe bakın
bu sefer ben açıklama yapmayacağım
kodu
siz kendiniz
çözümlemeye çalışın
sonra birlikte
üstünden geçelim
mehmet abi
bir thread bir fonksiyonu çalıştırıp
bittiğinde fonksiyon geri dönüş değerini alabiliyor muyuz?
burayı yine kaçırmış olmalısınız
iki üç kere söyledim
yanlış anlamayın
belki diğer arkadaşlarım da kaçırmıştır
dedim ki
thread nesnelerini kullanarak
bir fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini
koşturulan thread'den
onu koşturan thread'e
çarp thread'den
parent thread'e
geçme şansım yok
ve şöyle dedim
ama o zaman ne yapacağız?
dedim ki
bunun için başka araçlar var
işte konu çok geniş dedim ya
oraya doğru ilerliyoruz
şimdilik sadece
thread sınıfıyla ilgili
bunları görüyoruz
ha eğer çok kısa bir cevap istiyorsanız
arkadaşlar
yani bir fonksiyonun
thread'in çağırdığı fonksiyonun
geri dönüş değerini
kullanmak
söz konusuysa
böyle bir zorunluluk varsa
neler yapabiliriz?
isterseniz bir liste halinde vereyim
birincisi
şöyle primitif bir yol izleyebilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
yani örneğin o fonksiyon
geri dönüş değeri mekanizmasıyla değil de
başka bir şekilde
mesela global bir değişkeni
set ederek
torun altında
değeri öyle iletebilir
ama geri dönüş değeri
olmak zorundaysa
o zaman
ya yüksek seviyedeki
dedim ya farklı farklı
seviyelerde araçlar var
ya yüksek seviyedeki
async fonksiyonunu çağıracaksınız
onu uzun uzun göreceğiz
yani async fonksiyonunun
kendisi
bizim en az
2-3 saatimize olacak
ya da
async fonksiyonunun
yaptığını
siz kendiniz
yapacaksınız
işte async fonksiyonunun
yaptığını
kendinizin yapması için
iki ayrı sınıfı
kullanmanız gerekiyor
bu sınıflar
biri
stud future
diğeri de
stud promise
ha bir yanlış anlamı
olmasın
aslında async fonksiyonu da
stud future ve stud promise'i
kullanıyor
ama onları
gizliyor
onları
kol kırılır
yen içinde kalır
kendi implementasyonu da
gizliyor
dolayısıyla
burada o zaman
yollar
ya async isimli
fonksiyonu çağıracağız
ya da
kendimiz
future ve
promise nesneleri
oluşturup
fonksiyonların
geri dönüş değerini
arkadaşlar
İngilizce
shared state deniyor
future ve promise
nesneleriyle oluşturman
bu iki nesnenin
ortaklaşa kullandığı
bir kanalla
bir shared state ile
ileteceksiniz
ama oraya biraz
yolumuz var
doğrusunu isterseniz
peki
yani aslında
sorunuzun kısa cevabı
henüz görmedik bunu
yani kaçırdığınız yer
ben bunu henüz
görmedik dedim
belki orayı
kaçırmış olabilirsiniz
bir cümleydi sadece
evet şimdi bakalım
arkadaşlar
şimdi bu kodu
anlamanız da önemli
neyi sorguladığını
görmeniz önemli
çünkü kod biraz
karmaşık gibi
şimdi
fu isimli bir fonksiyon
var var isimli
bir fonksiyon
da var
fakat dikkat ederseniz
fu fonksiyonunda da
call once çağrısı
yapılmış
bar da da
arkadaşlar
call once çağrılmış
şimdi burada
özellikle şunu da
göstermiş oluyorum
yani
call once'ın
arkadaşlar tek bir fonksiyon
içinde çağrılması
gerekmiyor
önemli olan
o bir kere
çalıştırılacak
kodun
aynı
once flag
değişkenini
kullanması
yani şimdi
birden fazla
thread
fu ve bar
fonksiyonlarını
çalıştırıyor
olsa
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
arkadaşlar
ama
mesela bir thread
fu'yu çalıştırıyor
bir thread
bar'ı çalıştırıyor
ya da 10 tane
thread
fu'yu çalıştırıyor
eş zamanlı olarak
10 tane thread
bar fonksiyonunu
çalıştırıyor
yine
buradaki
call once çağrısına
konu olan
arkadaşlar
kod
yine bir kere mi
çalıştırılacak
cevap
evet
bravo
diyor ki
Mehmet Ali
öyleyse sadece
bir tanesi
fu ya da
bar çıkmalı
kesinlikle
bakın şimdi
koda bakalım
burada
ortaklaşa
kullanılan
once flag
değişkeni
ve burada
kolmans çağrısı
burada
neden
threadleri
100 milisaniye
uyuttuğumu
tahmin edebiliyor musunuz
ya çünkü
100 milisaniye
uyutmasam
belki
biri sürekli
daha önce
çağrılacak
yani daha önce
konstrak
dedilerinin
daha önce
çağrılma
ihtimali
daha yüksek
ama
bu şekilde
oluşturduğumda
artık
hangisinin
daha önce
çalışacağı
arkadaşlar
ne değil
bir
deterministik
değil
diğer türlü
de deterministik
değil ama
debug ederken
onu görme
ihtimalimiz
çok yüksek
evet
önceden
thread id
almış
thread bitmiş
ve new
thread
aynı
thread id
alabilir
herhangi bir
yolla
prosese
önceden
işlenmiş
bir thread
id
almasına
restriction
koyabilir miyiz
şimdi
tam olarak
belki soruyu
anlamamış
olabilirim
belki
kod üstünde
soruyu
incelemek
gerekiyor
ama
oluşturduğunuz
bir
threadde
arkadaşlar
thread'in
id'sini
siz
belirlemiyorsunuz
yani o
thread id
sizin
fonksiyona
geçtiğiniz
bir değer
değil
thread id
doğrudan
thread'i
oluşturan
constructor
tarafından
veriliyor
ama
belki
soruyu
yanlış
anlamış
olabilirim
isterseniz
bir
kod
üstünde
bakalım
ben
anlatırken
sizde
bir
kod
oluşturabilirseniz
tam olarak
ne yapılmak
istendiğini
anlamamış
olabilirim
ama
thread id'yi
kendimiz
seçemiyoruz
ya da
thread id'yi
restrict
edebilir miyiz
yani
thread id
şu olmasın
anlamında
mı
onu da
doğrudan
yapma
imkanımız
yok
şimdi
main
fonksiyondaki
koda
bakalım
bu
sefer
arkadaşlar
şimdi
farklı örneklerde
farklı
konteynerler
kullanıyorum
ki
sanki
stud
vektör
kullanmak
mecburiyeti
olmasın
unique
thread
id
gibi bir
imkan
var mı
yok
doğrudan
unique
thread
id
gibi bir
imkan
yok
arkadaşlar
evet
peki
şimdi
burada da
normal
c-ray
kullandım
mesela
stud
r
kullanabilirdim
list
arkadaşlar
vektör
kullanabilirdim
bu da
bildiğimiz
normal
arkadaşlar
c-dizisi
fix-ray
yani
fakat
10 kez
dönen bir
döngüde
yani
dizinin
boyutu
kadar
dönen bir
döngüde
bu
thread
vektörünün
i-indisi
elemanına
turner
operatör
kullanarak
yani
bir tek
bir çip
mesela
sıfır
için
arkadaşlar
şu
çalışacak
bir için
bu
çalışacak
iki
için
üç
yani
beş kere
fu
thread'i
beş kere
bar
thread'i
oluşturacak
ama
şimdi
olmaz da
hangisinin
bu
kodu
çalıştıracağı
yani
registered
in
for
registered
in
bar
belli değil
değil mi
buraya ilk
hangisi
girerse
onunki
çalışacak
mesela
diyelim ki
ilk
fu
çağrıldı
buradaki
kodu
fu
yürütürse
artık
bu
kod
şuradaki
kodla
bir daha
çalışmayacak
yani
bar
çağrılsa
bile
bu
çağrılacak
örneğin
verilme
nedenini
anlıyorsunuz
değil mi
sanki
mesela
farklı
fonksiyonlarda
kullandığım
zaman
farklı
kodlar
söz konusu
ymuş gibi
yine
burada
sonuçta
çalıştırılacak
kod
ya bu
çünkü aynı
mouse flag
değişkeni
kullanılmış
durumda
yine burada
bir şeye
daha dikkatinizi
çekeyim
burada
hep
c++
20 öncesinde
20 öncesi
için yazılmış
dolayısıyla
buradaki
threadlerin
join edilmesi
gerekiyor
burada
range
base
forluk
kullandığım
zaman
referans
semantini
kullanmasaydım
threadler
thread nesneleri
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapatılmış
olduğu için
syntax
hatası
olacaktı
ya
vektörü
konteynerı
neyse
onu dolaşıp
tek tek
threadleri
join edeceğim
ya da
başka bir
ihtimal
burada
dizi
pekala
c thread
dizisi de
olabilir
eğer
thread
c thread
dizisi ise
burada da
şöyle
olacak
arkadaşlar
böylece
artık
dizinin
hayatı
bittiğinde
dizi elemanları
destroy
edilecek
dizi elemanlarının
destroy
edilmesi
demek
c thread
nesnelerinin
destruct
edilmesi
demek
destruct
da
sarmadığı
thread'i
join
edecek
mesela
registered
in bar
ilk defa
burası
girmiş
çünkü
bakın
registered
info
görüyorsunuz
farklı
şimdi bakın
singleton
paternini
tekrar bir
hatırlayalım
singleton
konusunu
bir hatırlayalım
arkadaşlar
en basic
singleton
implementasyonu
ki
normalde
tercih edilecek
bir
implementasyon
değil
şöyle
değil mi
izleyin
bir hatırlatayım mı
evet
necaat
çok kısa
hatırlatırsam
iyi olur
arkadaşlar
singleton
örüntüsü
tek nesne
bütün kodların
eriştiği
belirli bir sınıf
türünden
tek bir nesne
olacak
ikinci bir nesne
oluşturulamayacak
o tek nesneyi de
bütün kodlar
kullanabilecek
şimdi
burada
dikkat edin
arkadaşlar
bütün problem
şu
get instance
fonksiyonu
çünkü
get instance
fonksiyonu
ilk kez
çağrıldığında
o tek nesneyi
diyelim ki
niv ifadesiyle
oluşturması
gerekiyor
ve onun
adresini
döndürmesi
gerekiyor
ama
ikinci kez
çağrıldığında
artık
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
ikinci kez
yaratmaması
gerekiyor
dolayısıyla
burada
dinamik ömürlü
nesnenin
bir kez
yaratılması
teması var
arkadaşlar
şimdi bakalım
yine burada
bir
neye
ihtiyacımız var
kolvans
çağrısına
ihtiyacımız var
işte bakın
burada kolvans
çağrısı
yapılıyor
takip edin
kolvans
çağrısı
m-init
flag'i
kullanıyor ki
m-init flag'i
sınıfın
statik veri
elemanı
yaptım
yine
singleton
nesnesinin
adresine
döndürecek
fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
ve
buradaki
get instance
fonksiyonu
işte buradaki
pointer'ı
döndürüyor
ama bu
pointer'ın
bir kez
initialize
edilmesi
gerekiyor
bir kez
initialize
edilmesini
sağlamak
için
get instance
fonksiyonu
içinde
kolvans'ı
çağırdım
ona
kolvul olarak
singleton'ın
init
fonksiyonunu
verdim
yani şu
fonksiyon
statik
üye fonksiyon
burada
m-instance'a
doğrudan
görüyorsunuz
binamik ömürlü
singleton
nesnesini
oluşturmak
için
new
ifadesi
kullanılmış
ve
m-instance'a
m-instance
veri elemanına
arkadaşlar
statik
veri elemanına
bu adres
atanmış
e şimdi
ben burada
bu önlemi
almasaydım
bu koda
get instance
fonksiyonuna
birden fazla
thread
girdiğinde
eğer doğrudan
burada bir
bayrak değişken
kullansam
dahi
bu koruma
olmayacaktı
aslında bunu
şöyle de
gösterebilirim
bakın
şimdi
önce bu örneği
tamamlayalım
sonra da
problemin ne olduğunu
ayrı bir örnekle
gösterelim
arkadaşlar
burada
fun fonksiyonu
içinde
get instance'ı
kullanıyorum
çağırıyorum
ve
100 tane
thread oluşturuyorum
eğer
100 tane
thread'ı
oluşturduğumda
burada dikkat
şuradaki
adreslerin
hepsinin aynı
olması gerekir
değil mi
buradaki
adreslerin
hepsi aynıysa
belli ki
bir tane
nesne
oluşturulmuş
ama buradaki
adreslerden
bir tane
bile farklı
varsa
yani iki
farklı adres
varsa
demek ki
bir şekilde
bunun
singleton
olma özelliği
thread safe
kodda
bozulmuş
oluyor
bu arada
tabi şunu da
söyleyelim
singleton'ın
thread safe
olma
zorunluluğu
da yok
singleton üzerinden
neden 100 tane
thread oluşturayım
singleton üstünden
100 tane
thread oluşturmuyorsunuz
emran bir şeyi
kaçırmış
olmalısınız
aslında
bu fonksiyon
singleton
nesnesine
kullanıyor
sadece benim
gösterdiğim yere
bakın
emran
burada
zaten singleton
tipik olarak
böyle kullanıyoruz
değil mi
singleton'ın
bir statiköye
fonksiyonu
oluyor
get instance
sadece beni izleyin
yani fun
fonksiyonu
burada neyi
temsil ediyor
singleton'ı
kullanan
kod
burayı
anladınız mı
dolayısıyla
funk'ı
ben
100 ayrı
thread'den
çalıştırsam
100 ayrı
thread'in de
kullandığı
singleton
nesnesinin
aynı nesne
olması
gerekir
değil mi
anlaşıldı mı
emran
evet
dolayısıyla
bunu da
nasıl
test ediyorum
get instance
funksiyonunu
çağırıp
singleton
nesnenin
adresini
elde ediyorum
ve bu
adresi
yazdırıyorum
eğer burada
singleton
olma özelliği
bozulmamışsa
yani
sadece
bir tane
nesne varsa
standart
output'a
yazılacak
adres
100 thread'de
de
aynı adres
olacak
şimdi
anladınız mı
evet
yani burada
100 tane
singleton
nesnesi
yaratmaya
çalışmıyorum
zaten
singleton
nesnesi
böyle bir
get instance
fonksiyonuyla
kullanılıyor
ama
get instance'ın
sadece ilk
çağrıldığında
singleton
nesnesini
dinamik ömürlü
nesneyi
oluşturması
gerekiyor
şimdi
runtime'a
bakın
Deniz iyi akşamlar
teşekkür ederim
bakın bütün
adresler aynı
ama ben şimdi
bu şekilde
olmayan
kötü bir
singleton
göstereyim
yani bunu
yapmasaydık
ne olurdu
biraz
beklerseniz
arkadaşlar
yazdığım bir
kodu
bulmaya
çalışıyorum
evet
siz de bu arada
koda bakın
evet
bakın şimdi
buldum
şimdi
izleyin
eğer
singleton
şöyle
olsaydı
ismini özellikle
böyle yazdım
thread
unsake
singleton
arkadaşlar
aslında
aynı kod
dikkat edin
burada
constructor
initializing
singleton
yazısını
çıkartıyor
yani
eğer
thread safe
olsaydı
buraya dikkat
thread safe
olsaydı
bu yazı
bir kere
çıkmalıydı
değil mi
önce bunu
bir bitirelim
alan ondan sonra
sorunuza cevap
vereyim
ama
bakın şimdi
eğer
thread safe
olma
garantisi
olmasaydı
normalde
singleton
paternine
böyle yazıyorduk
nasıl
aslında bir tane
arkadaşlar
pointer var
pointer'ın ilk değeri
null pointer
get singleton
fonksiyonun
içinde bir if
deyimi var
null pointer ise
bu if'in içine
giriyor
ve
singleton
mesnesini
oluşturuyor
Alihan önce
buraya dikkat edin
ve onun adresini
döndürüyor
şimdi eğer
thread safety
gerekmeseydi
gerçekten
get singleton
fonksiyonu
ilk kez
çağrıldığında
buradaki
statik veri
elemanı olan
mp
pointer'ı
false
değerde
olacaktı
dolayısıyla
ipin doğru
kısmına
girecekti
burada
mp'nin
değeri
değişip
değişecek
ve
oluşturulan
new ifadesiyle
singleton
nesnesinin
adresini
alacaktı
ama şimdi
eğer
multi thread
olarak
çalıştırılma
ihtimali
varsa
yani
get singleton
fonksiyonu
birden fazla
thread tarafından
çalıştırılması
söz konusuysa
o zaman
bu kod
kesinlikle
doğru değil
neden doğru
değil
ya son derece
basit
bu durumda
ben
mp
değişkenini
korumam
gerekiyor
değil mi
korumadım
yani örneğin
mp
false iken
programın
akışı
buraya girer
ama mp
değeri
değişmeden
bir başka
thread de
buraya girip
o da
ne yapabilir
bu kodu
çalıştırabilir
yani
bu klasik
bizim
singleton
kodumuz
thread safe
değil
şimdi
thread safe
olması için
ya burada
kendimin
mutual
exclusion
sağlamam
gerekiyor
dikkatli bir
şekilde
ya da
bu kodun
işte bir
önceki örnekte
olduğu gibi
sadece
bir kez
çalıştırılmasını
once flag
ve
call once
sağlamam
gerekiyor
şimdi bakın
burada yine
20 tane
thread oluşturuyorum
eğer
thread safe
olsaydı
bir tane
singleton
nesnesi
oluşacağı için
constructor
bir kere
çağrılacaktı
dolayısıyla
initializing
singleton
bit
yazısı
bir kere
yazacaktı
ama
thread safe
olmadığı için
neyi göreceğiz
büyük ihtimalle
20 tane
thread'den
bir tanesi
iki tanesi
üç tanesi
yine
bu kodu
çalıştıracak
ama neden
böyle bir hata
oluyor
aslında problem
şurada
yani
mp'nin
değerini
bir tanesi
değiştirse de
diğer thread
daha o değişmeden
o da buraya
girebilir
anlaşıldı mı
bakın
arkadaşlar
izleyin
initializing
singleton
bakın iki kere
bu kod çalıştı
belki üç kere
de çalışabilir
bakın üç kere
çalıştı
bakın
arkadaşlar
üç kere
çalıştı
peki
alan
bozkır
once flag'i
biz kendimiz
manipüle
edebiliyor
muyuz
hayır
once flag'i
biz manipüle
etmiyoruz
once flag için
tek yapmamız
gereken
once flag
nesnesini
default
construct
etmek
ve onu
kolbansa
argüman
olarak göndermek
yalnız bir şey
yanlış anlaşılmıyor
değil mi
diyelim ki
aynı kodda
bir kere
çalıştırılması
gereken
birden fazla
ayrı kod var
yani şöyle bir durum
düşünün
bir şey yanlış
anlaşılmasın
diyelim ki
fank fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
ve fank fonksiyonunda
burada
bununla dersi
kapatacağım
biraz sabırlı
olun
burada
kod
evet
ne diyelim
executed
once
burada böyle bir kod var
ama burada da böyle bir kod var
ama burada da
kod
executed
arkadaşlar
by
each
thread
şimdi
böyle bir yapı varsa
Arihan
burada aynı
once flag'i
kullanabilir miyiz
cevap
hayır
anladınız değil mi
burada o zaman
iki tane once flag
ve iki tane
kol vans
olacak
aynı once flag'i
bu şekilde
kullanmam
mümkün
değil
o zaman
zaten
bunu yürüttüğünde
bunu
bir kez daha
yürütmeyecek
peki bugünkü dersimizde
burada sona eriyor
bir dahaki hafta
yine daha
konkurenci konularının
görece olarak
çok başındayız
epey devam edecek
yani büyük ihtimalle
kalan derslerimizin
hepsi değil ama
büyük çoğunluğu
konkurenci
alt başlıklarıyla
devam edecek
herkese
arkadaşlar
şimdiden
iyi bir hafta sonu
diliyorum
ve derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
görüşmek üzere
abone ol